THIS HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ORDER --
WILL THE SECRETARY.
THIS CALL THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM.
BUT I DON'T.
O'DONNELL HERE O'DONNELL HERE
KILEY.
KILEY HERE KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
SMITH.
SMITH HERE VOEPEL [inaudible]
WEBER.
WOOD.
OKAY.
CAN WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE'RE GONNA DO IS START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE -- ONCE THE COURT HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
THIS HEARING ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VOEPEL WILL BE JOINING US
SHORTLY HE IS A SITTING IN ON
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE AS A
MEMBER TODAY.
SO WE WELCOME HIM CERTAINLY.
WE HAVE TWENTY SEVEN BILLS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY INCLUDING SIX
ON CONSENT.
THE CONSENT ITEMS ARE AS FOLLOWS
AB.
ONE TWO FOUR AB ONE TWO FIVE AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN A. B.
FIFTEEN OH EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
AB. SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE WHETHER
IT'S AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
THOSE ARE THE BILLS ON CONSENT.
FOR MEASURES HAVE BEEN PULLED
FROM THE AGENDA THEY ARE AS
FOLLOWS AB SEVEN SIXTY AB. TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT A. EIGHTY FIFTEEN
SEVENTY NINE AB. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY ONE SIX SEVENTEEN SIXTY
ONE I WOULD.
LIKE TO REMIND ALL OTHERS THAT
THEY GET TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES FOR EACH WITNESS. TO
AUTHORS AND SUPPORT TO AUTHORS
OPPOSED TO TO INTO.
A TWO MINUTES FOR EACH AGAIN TWO
WITNESSES ON EACH SIDE THEN
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAY COME
AFTER THE AFTER THE SUPPORT HAS
COME UP.
THEN WE'LL GO TO THE OPPOSITION
IF YOU ARE A MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND YOU WISH YOU TO A
PINE -- ON ONE OF THE BILLS YOU
MAY COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE OR
WHAT WE CALL WHEN IT IS TIME AND
YOU MAY STATE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY.
A WITH THAT WHY DON'T WE START
WITH OUR FIRST BILL AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE HAVE NO OTHERS HERE DO WE WE
WE HAD SOME ANIME SOME IF
THEY'RE STAFF LISTENING THE US
AND THEY'RE ALL THEY'RE DOWN
HERE NOW BECAUSE OF THE FIRST
[inaudible]
MR KILEY [inaudible]
OKAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO GIVE MY ADVISER
. TEN EIGHTY
NINE A WEEK.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TEN ASSEMBLY
BILL AND NINE ZERO EIGHT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS.
AB NINE AWAY WILL PROVIDE
TEACHERS WITH THE BANK OF
RELEASED TAX TAXED ITEMS FROM
THE STATE'S ANNUAL ASSESSMENT
FOR USE.
AS A FORMATION ASSESSMENT TOOL.
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT IS A
POWERFUL PRACTICE TEACHERS USE.
TO CHECK HOW OTHER STUDENTS ARE
LEARNING AND HE USED AND THE USE
RESULTS TO IMPROVE THEIR
INSTRUCTION.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A STATE
RIGHT SCHOOLS WITH FORMATIVE
ASSESSMENT TOOLS.
THE STATE MEETS THE REQUIREMENTS
REQUIREMENT BY PROVIDING
TEACHERS WITH ACCESS TO A
DIGITAL LIBRARY OF LESSONS IN
WHICH FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT IS
EMBEDDED.
IN THEORY.
BUT THERE ARE SOME LIMITATIONS
TO THIS APPROACH TEACHERS MAY
NOT TO SHOOT CHOOSE TO USE THESE
LESSONS
THE FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT
RESOURCES IN THE DIGITAL LIBRARY
CAN BE INCONSISTENT AND FORMAT
AND QUALITY.
I CAN WILL ATTEST TO THAT.
IN THE FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT
RESOURCES DO NOT NECESSARILY
ALIGN WITH THE WAY PROFICIENCY
IS ASSESSED.
ON THE SUMMATIVE ASSESSMENT.
AGAIN SOME MOTIVE IS AT THE END
OF THE YEAR FORMATIVE IS IS IS
IS THE ENTER.
IT CAN HAPPEN DALY CHEN
AFFECTION HAVE THAT HAPPEN DALY
DOESN'T NECESSARILY A CHEST BUT
AS A CHECK IN TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT STUDENTS ARE MASTERING.
THE OTHER CONTENT YOU'RE TRYING
TO CONVEY TO THEM.
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS CURRENTLY
HAVE ACCESS TO SOME SAMPLE TEST
ITEMS BUT THEY'RE LIMITED IN
NUMBER NOT ORGANIZED BY STANDARD
AND CONTAINED FEW PERFORMANCE
TASK IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO BELIEVE THAT
WE'RE WE ARE WHERE WE ARE --
WITH WITH THE US BACK TODAY THE
SHOULD BE.
A REGULAR PART OF THE TEACHER
SHOULD HAVE READ -- READILY
AVAILABLE ACCESS TO TO THESE
KINDS OF OF PERFORMANCE TASK AND
AS AN S. ASSESSMENTS FORMATIVE
ASSESSMENTS.
OTHER STATES AS WELL AS OTHER
NATIONAL ASSESSMENT CONSORTIUM
PROVIDES EXTENSIVE COLLECTIONS
OF RELEASED TEST ITEMS.
AS WELL AS SCORING GUIDES AND
SAMPLES OF STUDENT WORK.
TEACHERS IN THESE STATES CAN USE
THESE RESOURCES AS FORMATIVE
ASSESSMENT TOOLS.
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS SHOULD HAVE
THE SAME KIND OF RESOURCES.
AB NINE OH ABLE GIVE TEACHERS A
POWERFUL TOOL TO USE AND
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT.
WHICH WILL ENABLE THEM TO
IMPROVE THEIR TEACHING. TO HELP
THEIR STUDENTS MASTER
EDUCATIONAL PROFICIENCY.
BUT WITH ME -- IN SUPPORT TODAY
IS.
BILL LUCY A MAYBE.
BUT I I I IT MUST MEMBER MISTER
LUCY WERE HERE HE WOULD SAY THIS
IS A FINAL BILL THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR.
THIS IS GOING TO HELP MOVE
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS.
FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD.
GREAT A GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
AND MUCH THOUGHT OR SOME HAVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS -- OR ACCESS AND
SUPPORT WE BELIEVE IN AB NINE
AWAIT IS A GOOD MEASURE VERY
GOOD MEASURE BECAUSE THEY
PROVIDE A TOOL IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FOR TEACHERS ARE FREE.
OF CHARGE THEIR OPTIONAL TOOLS
THAT CAN HELP INFORM INSTRUCTION
WE BELIEVE THE MORE TOWARD THE
TEACHERS HAVE TO ADD TO IT FROM
WHAT THEY DO EVERY DAY IN THE
CLASSROOM IS BETTER FOR KIDS --
THE FACT THAT AND THEY ARE
AVAILABLE ON A FOR FREE OF
CHARGE I'M MEANS THEY CAN USE A
MUST PARA PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
IT ON THAT SCHOOL PRINCIPALS CAN
HELP SUPPORT TEACHERS -- AND
THEREFORE WE SUPPLY REQUEST OR
UNSUPPORTED ON EIGHTY NINE AWAIT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE ORIGINAL
INTENSE WHEN WE ORIGINALLY START
DOING THE ASPECT THAT THIS TYPE
OF INFORMATION WOULD BE
AVAILABLE AND USABLE.
THIS BILL MAKE IT USABLE FOR
TEACHERS AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR SHARE MEMBERS
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY EVA RIGHT NOW
ON BEHALF OF ED VOICE IN FULL
SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'M
STRAIGHT ON ALL YES I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WHAT YOU'LL NOTICE
ABOUT THIS BILL IS IT DOESN'T
HAVE A SPONSOR.
THIS IS BECAUSE IT COMES FROM MY
OWN CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE MY OWN
EXPERIENCE AS A TEACHER.
TEACHERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
NEEDED TO LIKE THIS TO HELP MOVE
THEIR STUDENTS FORD SO WHAT WHEN
THE TIME COMES I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'LL BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN
IT COMES TO A VOTE WHICH WE'LL
TAKE UP ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WHEN?
I SPOKE.
FORTY WELL NOW MOVE THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER -- SEVENTEEN MISTER
GIBSON AB
.
ELEVEN NINETY SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN WAITING FOR
THE RETAIN OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION
TO UNDERSTAND HE IS -- THE
WALKING THROUGH THE DOOR ANY
MOMENT NOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE HAVE MISSED
A MONTH AGO.
I'M SORRY WE HAVE MR MAULING I
THINK HE'S WAITING FOR THE SAME
PERSON.
IS NOT.
MISTER MOM WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO MR MOE HE GAVE YOU A CHANCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A
LETTER.
OF A ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN NINETY
SIX WHICH SEEKS TO ECSTATIC TO
STATEWIDE A MODEL FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS CURRENTLY THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED THROUGHOUT
THE LOCAL.
THROUGHOUT LOCAL -- INITIATIVES
AND GIVES -- POSITIVE RESULTS WE
BELIEVE.
IT IS TIME FOR THE STATE TO STEP --
AND TAKE THE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BY SUPPORTING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WORK --
BECAUSE IT INVOLVES AN APPROACH
THAT FOCUSED ON THE WHOLE CHILD
RATHER THAN SIMPLY EDUCATING THE
CHILD COMMUNITY SCHOOL SEEKS TO
INTEGRATE MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS A
REFORM THE CULTURE OF THE
SCHOOLS TO INCREASE PARRIS
ENGAGEMENT.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICES
AND EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS THAT
AFFIRMS OF THE DIVERSITY OF THE
SCHOOL COMMUNITY SCHOOLS SIX TO
MAKE THE SCHOOL SITE NOT JUST A
CAMPUS FOR TEACHERS AND STUDENTS.
BUT A KEY CENTER FOR THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT HERE WITH
ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY OF FOUR ELEVEN NINETY
SIX IS THE FORMER COLLEAGUE --
IN STATE ASSEMBLY MY GOOD FRIEND
AND NEW SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION THEY WERE HAPPY
THESE SPONSORING THIS BILL
MISTER TONY THURMOND.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX I WOULD JUST ADD EMPHASIS TO
WHAT THE AUTHOR HAS SAID -- WE
KNOW THAT -- COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PROVIDE NEEDED PROGRAMS TO HELP
STUDENTS IN THE AREAS OF HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT CAN REMOVE
BARRIERS TO GET IN THE WAY.
OF STUDENT SUCCESS -- YOU KNOW
BEFORE SERVING IN GOVERNMENT I
SERVED AS A SOCIAL WORKER AND
WORKED A LOT OF SCHOOL BASED
SETTINGS AND SAW STUDENTS WHO
WERE IMPACTED BY TRAUMA.
OR HOMELESSNESS OR POVERTY OR
OTHER ISSUES.
CAN BE SCHOOLS PROVIDE THE
FRAMEWORK FOR HELPING.
TO REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS AND
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR
LEARNING ABOUT THIS BILL WILL
CREATE A THREE YEAR GRANT
PROGRAM TO HELP SCHOOLS DESIGN
THE RIGHT PROGRAM AND TO HELP
THEM.
IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
OUR SKILLS OUR STUDENTS I LIKE
TO THINK THE COMEDIAN STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US TO REFINE THE
CONCEPTS IN THE DELIVERY
MECHANISMS.
AND THANK LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION FOR SHARING
THEIR PERSPECTIVES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
DR DEBORAH TOMORROW.
AND LIKE OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND SHE
TOO IS A SOCIAL WORKER.
AND AN EDUCATOR AS
SUPERINTENDENT ORDER THOUGH HAS
STARTED TOM INFORM SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT THE LA COUNTY AND HIS
WORK WITH OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
PARTNERS.
AND WE'RE ALSO INTERESTED OF
VERY MUCH AND COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
SOME OF THE GOALS THAT WE HAVE
FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ARE
IMPROVING STUDENT OUTCOMES
SUPPORTING TRAUMA AND RESILIENCY
INFORMED PRACTICES AND
STRENGTHENING COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS BY BUILDING NEW
ALLIANCES AND NETWORKS.
AND SOME OF THOSE COMMUNITY
PARTNERS THAT WE HAVE OUR CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES.
AND THOSE ARE SOME OF OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS WE ALSO HAVE PUBLIC
HEALTH PUBLIC LIBRARIES
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION
AND OTHERS AND WE THINK BRINGING
ALL OF THEM TOGETHER WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE WHOLE CHILD NEEDS.
THAT WERE EXPRESSED -- BY -- OUR
CO SPONSOR.
SPONSOR AND AUTHOR SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
KEVIN FROM AROUND HALF THE
COMPTON A FIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICT
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FLEXIBLE
EDUCATORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MORE SECONDS ALSO ME HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
A SCENE OPPOSITIONOPPOSITION TO
THE BILL ANY COMMENTS READY TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
MISS SMITH.
AND IT JUST TO CLARIFY YOU ARE
SET YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS.
I'M EXCEPT IMMENSELY THANK THE
COMMITTEE.
I JUST LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
SUPERINTENDENT FOR THIS MEASURE
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WE
KNOW THERE'S ALREADY SOME BEST
PRACTICE MODELS HAPPENING OUT
THERE GIVING THESE FOLKS MORE
RESOURCES TO DEVELOP WHAT'S
GOING TO BE THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT TOOL THE NEXT PHASE OF
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR
US IS.
SIGNIFICANT SO I THINK BOTH OF
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT.
I SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS FROM ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THE MOTION
IS.
TO NO WE DON'T NEED A MOTION
WELL.
OKAY.
YOU MAY CLOSE -- WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE -- THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AS WELL AS ITS CHAIRMAN
AND THE COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHAT I VOTE THIS IS GOING
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THINK.
OUR SPONSOR SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION FALSO
ADVOCATING LEAD THE WAY IN THE
SPACE OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
AND COURSE ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE WILL.
TAKE THE VOTE -- MISTER MALL IN.
IS IS AN AXES -- ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE I SO I THINK IT'S TO THE
OTHER ONE WHICH ONE ARE YOU
DOING.
MISTER CHAIR WERE LOOKING TO
TAKE OF AB FIVE SEVEN EIGHT
WHILE.
OUR SUPERINTENDENT IS HERE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX AB [inaudible]
FIVE SEVENTY I'VE.
SEVENTY GOOD AFTERNOON I GOT A
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THANK
MANY STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK
ON THE BILL.
AB FIVE SEVEN EIGHT ESTABLISHES
THE CALIFORNIA STEM TEACHING
PATHWAY ACTIVE. TWENTY NINETEEN
FOR THE PURPOSE OF RECRUITING
PREPARING SUPPORTING AND
RETAINING QUALIFIED STEM
PROFESSIONALS AS MATHEMATICS
SCIENCE IN COMPUTER SCIENCE
TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AN APPROPRIATE TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT PURPOSE.
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC STRENGTH
IS ROOTED IN STEM PROFESSIONS
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA
SHORTAGE OF QUALIFIED MATH AND
SCIENCE TEACHERS THREATENS THE
FUTURE WORK FORCE AND ECONOMIC
WELL BEING OF THE STATE.
WITH A PROJECTED SHORTAGE OF
MORE THAN THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
MATH AND SCIENCE TEACHERS.
CURRENT RECRUITMENT AND
PREPARATION APPROACHES ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT.
IF WE DO NOT INCREASE THE
PIPELINE OF TEACHERS QUALIFIED
TO TEACH THEM CLASSES WE WILL
NOT MEET THE DEMAND FOR JOBS IN
THE SECTORS.
THAT ARE CONTINUOUSLY
EXPERIENCING GROWTH CREATING
PATHWAYS FOR PROFESSIONALS
VETERANS AND CURRENT TEACHERS TO
BECOME STEM TEACHERS WILL BILL
THAT PIPELINE.
THIS GRANT PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE
FUNDING TO PROMOTE THE
TRANSITION OF SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATH INDUSTRY
PROFESSIONALS AND RETIREES INTO
THE TEACHING PROFESSION.
WITH ME TODAY IT'S A SPONSOR OF
THE BILL.
MY GOOD FRIEND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AND
OUR CHIEF SUPPORTER HERE TO
TESTIFY [inaudible]
YES SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SEVEN MEMO IF YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE -- HERE
JUST TO ADD OUR SUPPORT FOR AB --
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT WE WOULD
CONCUR WITH WHAT YOU HEARD AND
AND NOT REPEATED ONLY TO ADD
EMPHASIS THAT -- IF THERE WILL
BE A MILLION AND A HALF JOBS AND
TECHNOLOGY TO FEW YEARS AND
PROBABLY HALF OF THE APPLICANTS
FOR THOSE JOBS UNLESS WE CHANGE
THE WAY WE PREPARE OUR STUDENTS.
FOR THE JOBS OF TOMORROW THAT
MEANS THAT THEY'VE GOT TO HAVE
ACCESS TO MORE COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND MORE MATH AND SCIENCE THAT
MEANS WE NEED EDUCATORS WHO CAN
PROVIDE THAT.
THIS BILL CREATES A PATHWAY FOR
SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO BECOME A
TEACHER ONE OF THOSE FEELS OR
WHO IS A TEACHER WHO WANTS TO
MOVE INTO THAT AREA.
THIS BILL ENVISIONS WAYS DO
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
FOR EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
OTHERS IN OTHER SOMEBODY WENT
OUT MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M
VINCE STEWART WITH CHILDREN NOW
I'M ALSO THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STEM NETWORK.
WHICH IS A STATEWIDE PARTNERSHIP
OF K. TWELVE HIGHER DUCATION --
BUSINESS AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
ADVANCING STEM EDUCATION.
MORE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT WE THINK
IT'LL MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN TERMS OF
RECRUITING AND RETAINING STEM
TEACHERS.
I THINK IT'S WELL DOCUMENTED THE
SWORDS IN THE STATE OF THESE
TEACHERS PARTICULARLY IN THE
SUBJECTS AND IN SMALL IN RURAL
DISTRICTS -- ENROLLMENT CENTER
TEACHER EDUCATION PROGRAMS HAVE
GROWN BUT NOT GROWING FAST
ENOUGH AND WE KNOW IT'S NOT
GOING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
TEACHERS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
NEED OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS --
WE BE CURRENTLY THAT -- THAT
SHORTAGE IS BEING FILLED BY
TEACHERS WHO ARE LESS THAN
QUALIFIED -- IN THOSE TEACHERS
ARE TEACHING IN SCHOOLS THAT ARE
PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME AND
MINORITY STUDENTS.
SO WE FEEL THAT THIS WILL GO A
LONG WAY TO ADDRESSING THAT
ISSUE -- RECRUITMENT OR SHOULD
SAY RETENTION IS A BIG ISSUE AS
WELL AND IN OAKLAND UNIFIED WERE
MY DAUGHTER IS A STUDENT -- THEY
LOSE ABOUT A THIRD OF THEIR
TEACHERS NEW TEACHERS EVERY
THREE YEARS SO I THINK AB FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO BRING NEW PEOPLE INTO THE
PROFESSION.
AND TO RETAINING THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY THERE SO I ARCHER I
THOUGH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CARE TO MEMBERS BROKAW HERE ON
BEHALF OF MICROSOFT CORPORATION
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
KEVIN FROM ROOM HALF THE COMP
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
SCHOOL EDUCATORS AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAMERA DIMITRI WITH TECHNO AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
MY HAVE A RIGHT NOW WITH ADVICE
AND SUPPORT.
OKAY TAKE ONE SECOND HERE AND I
LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM OF
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
O'DONNELL HERE O'DONNELL HERE
KILEY.
KILEY HERE KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE SMITH SMITH HERE
VOEPEL WEBER.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU I
WITH THAT -- DO WE HEAR FROM ALL
THE SUPPORT.
YES OKAY -- ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
ANY OPPOSITION WILL SING
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK
ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED DO WE HAVE A
SECOND BY MISTER MCCARTY.
MOVED AND SECONDED -- BUT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY CLOSE.
CLASS FIVE A POSTURE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH SMITH I
VOEPEL WEBER.
THE BILLS OUT US FOR VOICE
[inaudible]
MEANTIME [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO JUMP.
TO I DON'T KNOW.
SORRY MR MAIENSCHEIN TYPICALLY
RIGHT OR FILE ITEM NUMBER DOWN
IN OUR IN OUR BILL NUMBER NOW WE
PUT OUR NAME HERE.
YOURS IS BLANK.
WHAT IS IT? TWENTY THREE FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN AB.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FOUR AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WE DON'T HAVE THAT
ON THE SHOW SO.
I THINK SOMEONE WRITE YOUR NAME
DOWN FOR YOU DON'T WORRY ABOUT.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY YOU
DID DID A GOOD JOB NORTE.
NEW TO THIS GAME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'VE MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- I WANT TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS HAS PROPOSED -- IN
THE ANALYSIS AND I'M VERY
PLEASED AUTHOR A. B. SIXTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND.
THE BILL CREATES AN ONGOING
PROGRAM FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
EDUCATORS IN TEACHING READING
AND LITERACY ACROSS GRADES AND
ACROSS CONTENT AREAS.
LITERACY IS MORE THAN JUST THE
ABILITY TO READ AND WRITE GOOD
LITERACY EDUCATION CREATES A
FOUNDATION THAT ENABLES OUR
STUDENTS TO GROW AND TO INFORM
CITIZENS.
BE SUCCESSFUL AND PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE ECONOMIC
VITALITY OF THE STATE.
PROVIDING SUPPORT AND RESOURCES
FOR TEACHERS SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS TO INVEST IN LITERACY
EDUCATIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE IS
NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR STUDENTS
TO HAVE THE BEST CHANCES AT
SUCCESS.
TODAY'S DIVERSE STUDENTS NEED TO
BE PREPARED FOR TOMORROW'S
LITERACY DEMANDS.
UP WITH ME TODAY.
AS YOU SEE IS THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND WHO
WILL ALSO AT TESTIFIED SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU SOME
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN -- HERE TO
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A FRAMEWORK TO
SUPPORT TEACHERS AND
PROFESSIONAL.
DEVELOPMENT -- TO SUPPORT
LITERACY -- AS YOU HEARD IT
LEARNING TO READ BY THIRD GRADE
IS A CRITICAL BENCHMARK -- MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS DO NOT MEET IT
TO SHARE WITH YOU JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF DATA ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CHANGE THE NEAR WE
WANT TO CHANGE.
IS IF YOU LOOK AT ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS IN 201865% OF
WHITE STUDENTS IN 76% OF ASIAN
STUDENTS MET OR EXCEEDED
STANDARDS FOR CHEAP IT.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME ONLY 39%
OF LATINO STUDENTS IF 32% OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS AND
38% OF ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS MET OR
EXCEEDED STANDARDS THIS IS THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
CHANGE I APPRECIATE AND THE WAY
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
YOUR WORK IN HELPING US TO SHAPE
THE FRAMEWORK AND HOW WE DO MORE.
TO SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL LEARNING --
WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE WORK WITH
TEACHERS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
HELP THEM BE COMFORTABLE WORKING
WITH STUDENTS AND LEARNING TO
LOVE READING THAT WHEN YOU LEARN
TO READ YOU READ TO LEARN.
AND WE KNOW THIS IS A BILL THAT
WILL HELP MANY OF OUR SIX
BILLION STUDENTS IN THE STATE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTE.
FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
I WANTED TO INTRODUCE ONE OF OUR
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT WHO'S HERE
THE STAFF HAS MORE QUESTIONS
THIS IS CATALINA SUPPORT THIS
WHO OVERSEES MANY OF OUR
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD INCLUDE
LITERACY AND SHE'S HERE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ONE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AWESOME
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SAY NO THERE'S A SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION SAYING NO OPPOSITION
WILL BRING IT BACK BEHIND.
THE COMMITTEE -- ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SING UNTO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH SMITH I
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WEBER.
THE BILL US FOR THREE VOTE SO IT
IS ON CALL [inaudible]
AND AT THIS MAJOR.
SO MR MULLIN YOU'RE COMING BACK
UP [inaudible]
ARE THE AND I DON'T KNOW.
FILE ITEM FIVE A. B.. FOUR FOUR
FIVE TWO FOUR FIVE TWO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
THANK MEDI STAFF AGAIN FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL.
AB FOR FIFTY TWO WHICH I'M ALL
THROUGH WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY MEMBER THIS COMMITTEE.
SEEKS TO CONVERT THE CALIFORNIA
CHILD CARE FACILITIES REVOLVING
FUNDS INTO THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
CARE FACILITIES GRANT FIND.
REPORTS OF THE LEGISLATURE OVER
THE LAST DECADE REFLECT THAT THE
FUND HAS BEEN SEVERELY UNDER
UTILIZED.
DURING THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FISCAL YEAR THE
REVOLVING FUND DID NOT RECEIVE A
SINGLE APPLICATION.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OVERHAUL THE
FUNDING CONVERTED TO A GRAND
FUND OF COME FROM BRIEFS BY THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT AND A DRAFT
OF THE SPEAKERS BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY CHRISTOPHER
MARKEL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
HEAD START CALIFORNIA AND ANGIE
GARLING NATIONAL EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION DIRECTOR FOR THE LOW
INCOME INVESTMENT.
FUND AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ABOUT.
YOU YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS FOR
MIRACLE -- FOR HISTORY
CALIFORNIA -- REPRESENTING THE
HUNDRED FIFTY GRANTEES AGENCIES
THAT SERVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN -- IF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
AT RISK CHILDREN ZERO TO FIVE
WE'RE GRATEFUL -- TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN AFTER BRINGING
FORTH THIS BILL -- THE SERVICE
GAP FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS A
SHOOTING THREE IS WELL
DOCUMENTED AS WELL AS THE LACK
OF FACILITIES -- THIS
LEGISLATION DOES TO GREAT THINGS.
IT MAKES MORE FUNDING AVAILABLE.
FOR FACILITIES DEVELOPED TO
SERVE THOSE CHILDREN.
AND IT MAKES THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO MORE INCLUSIVE
RANGE OF PROVIDERS AND THAT IS
ESSENTIAL BECAUSE ARE MIXED
DELIVERY SYSTEM INCLUDES
DIFFERENT KINDS OF AGENCIES WHO
OFFER BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE
FUNDED PROGRAMS -- WE BELIEVE
THE INCLUSIVITY WILL HELP
INCENTIVIZE PROVIDERS TO CREATE
NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR CARE FOR
OUR YOUNGEST CITIZENS AND HEAD
START CALIFORNIA IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT WITNESS GREAT
THANK YOU ANGIE GARLING WITH THE
LOW INCOME INVESTMENT FUND TO
ADDRESS -- WHY THE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDED THE OPTION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO CONTRACT WITH ONE
OR MORE CDF EYES?
SO THE LOW INCOME INVESTMENT
FUND IS A C. DFI THAT IS A
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION -- LIST AS ONE OF
THE LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY AND
BASICALLY WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT WE'RE A NONPROFIT BANK.
WERE MISSION DRIVEN AND WE WORK --
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TO DEVELOP CHILD
CARE HOUSING -- FOOD IS A
FACILITIES THINGS THAT WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE NEEDS IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES -- IN TERMS OF
CHILDCARE WE HAVE NATIONALLY
INVESTED -- A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND TO
PRESERVE THEIR EXPANDED TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
SPACES SO THE ADVANTAGES FOR
USING A C. DFI ARE REALLY TO THE
FIRST IS THAT IT LEVERAGES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
SO YOU CAN. FOR EVERY DOLLAR
INVESTED IN TO THE MAIN MARKETS
WE WORK IN RIGHT NOW SAN
FRANCISCO AND WASHINGTON DC.
YOU GET THREE DOLLARS IN --
FUNDING SO IF THE IF THERE'S
FUNDING INVESTED THEN WE WILL WE
HAVE CDF EYES SPECIALIZE IN
BEING ABLE TO FINANCE AND HELP
PACKAGE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
PROJECTS THROUGH LOANS AND
GRANTS WE HAVE EXPERIENCE IN
WORKING WITH -- AND CDF EYES
HAVE EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
CENTERS AS WELL AS FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WITH LOANS GRANTS
AND THE SECOND REASON THAT CDF
EYES ARE IMPORTANT IN THE MIX IS
THROUGH THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT THEY PROVIDE.
THEY PROVIDE WE PROVIDE ROBUST
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THE AT
THE BEGINNING SO WE MAKE SURE
THAT NO PROJECTS GO FORWARD
UNLESS THERE SHOVEL READY AND
HAVE SOUND FINANCING -- AND THEN
TA ON THE OTHER END TO ENSURE
THAT THE INVESTMENT IS IS SOUND
SO WITH FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WE WILL FOLLOW A FIVE
THOUSAND OR TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR --
GRANT OR LOAN FOR AT LEAST THREE
YEARS UP TO THIRTY YEARS FOR ONE
MILLION DOLLARS -- INVESTMENT SO
WE WE ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
INVESTMENT -- IS IS SOUNDS AND
IS -- MADE.
MADE TO INSURE THAT THE CHILDREN --
BENEFIT ON AN ONGOING BASIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
AARON GAVE ON THE HAVE A FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DAVID HAS BEEN FROM CALIFORNIA'S
FOR QUALITY EARLY LEARNING IN
SUPPORT.
I NEED A BOTH THE EVER TALK
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR STRONG
SUPPORT.
VALERIE DINERO EVER TELL
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT.
DEFERRED TEARS TRIAL THREE SIXTY
LOS ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT.
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR EARLY
LEARNING MISSION NEIGHBORHOOD
CENTERS AND THE FACILITIES
CAMPAIGN COALITION ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAITLYN JENNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ALLIANCE OF
YMCAS IN SUPPORT.
THE INTO THE READ ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION STRONG SUPPORT.
DEBORAH BROWN ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE STILL PREVENTS HE ON
BEHALF OF TODAY GO IN SUPPORT.
HOW DO YOU BRING YOUR CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILY CHILD CARE?
PROVIDERS CAN PARTICIPATE AND
ASSUMING WE CAN WORK IT OUT
THANK YOU JUST A SECOND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOUR MAILLET DILLMAN SAN MATTEO
COUNTY CHILDCARE PARTNERSHIP
COUNCIL AND THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
CARE COORDINATORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
JEFF BACA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT.
BUT IT IS IN THE SUN OR THE AGE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT. THIRTY THREE
THE CEO OF GO KIDS A CHILD OF
ELEMENT AGENCY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
MACKENZIE QUESTIONS THEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CARRIE ROBERTS OWNER OF ALPHABET
SOUP CHILD CARE AND YOLO COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT.
HE SENDS A WE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER FROM NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE LA IN SUPPORT.
JIMMY FROM YOUR FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I SEE NO THERE'S A
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
SOON OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS READY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SIX MR MCCARTY.
YES -- I AM A A A JOINT AUTHORED
HERE SO IT'S KIND OF AWKWARD I'M
ASKING A TOUGH QUESTION ABOUT A
BILL THAT MY NAME IS ON BUT ONE
THING THAT -- I KNOW WE TALKED
TO YOU ABOUT OUR OTHER MISTER
CHAIR AND A COMMITTEE STAFF
ABOUT THERE ARE OTHER -- BOND
PROPOSAL AND FACILITIES IS.
WITH THE LA ETS AND THAT THE NON
ELEAZAR AND CERTAINLY IT'S A
MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR ALL
EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS INVENT
TOLAR PROGRAMS DON'T TALK A
PROGRAMS AND PRE K..
AND SO WITH PUBLIC MONEY WITH
NON GOVERNMENT ENTITIES ITS IT'S
YOU KNOW WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
FOCUS ON PROTECTING OUR TAXPAYER
INTEREST SO WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION THING JUST ONE
THING I KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT GOING FORWARD.
IS IF THERE IS IT AT WHOLESALE
NEW CONSTRUCTION AND THE NEW.
PROGRAM WITH THE GRANT AND NOT
ALONE IS HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE
PROTECT THAT THE THE PUBLIC
INTERESTED IN OTHER WORDS.
IS THERE LIKE A IS THERE LIKE A
CO SIGNER LACK OF BETTER WORD
THAT SAID.
PARK DISTRICT IS A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR SOMETHING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE.
GETTING THE MOST OUT OF OUR
PUBLIC DOLLAR.
I WILL ALLOW MY EXPERTS A SHOT
AT THAT BUT I JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE THAT WE HAVE -- BACK
THE ELIGIBLE ENTITIES THAT CAN
RECEIVE THE FUNDS. TO THOSE THAT
HAVE A HISTORY OF PROVIDING
CHILDCARE WHERE THERE'S LITTLE
RISK OF LOSING ALL PUBLIC FUNDS
TO PRIVATE ENTITIES THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME ISSUES IN THE PAST IN
THAT REGARD I KNOW THERE'S A
CONCERN THERE.
BUT ALL ALLOW -- ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT ON THE NO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT -- CDF I THINK A
LOT ABOUT ENDS UP FIRST OF ALL
WE PROVIDE STRONG TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SO APPROACH A PROJECT
WILL BE READY UNLESS WE KNOW IT
HAS SOUND FINANCING.
AND THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT WE PROVIDE TO MITIGATE RISK
ON THE OTHER END IS -- EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO THE C. DFI AND
THERE ARE OTHER OPTIONS AS WELL
TO PROVIDE MITIGATION OF RESPITE
TENSELY PARTNERING WITH -- FILL
IN PHILANTHROPY TO PUT UP EQUITY
THERE'S OTHER -- CREATIVE WAYS
THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT --
THERE'S NO GIFT A PUBLIC FUND
THE OTHER THING THAT I'LL SAY IS
THAT IT IS VERY VERY UNLIKELY IN
ALL THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
WITH A LOW INCOME INVESTMENT
FUND. TO HAVE ANY KIND OF
DEFAULTS WE WE WORK REALLY
CLOSELY TO ENSURE THAT THROUGH
THE LOAN OR GRANT PROCESS.
THE PROVIDER COMES UP MUCH
STRONGER FROM A BUSINESS AND ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
WELL I GUESS Là THEY GIVE A
HYPOTHETICAL AND GRANT IS TO BE
NUKES HAVE BEEN GIVING LOANS OUT
THEY WEREN'T AS ATTRACTIVE NOW
THE A GRANT.
AND THAT THE OTHER THING IS IF
HAVING PROPER REIMBURSEMENT FOR
THESE PROGRAMS WHICH FOR HAVE
ANOTHER IDEA FOR THAT.
LATER ON BUT WHAT IF THERE IS
YOU KNOW A NEW OPERATOR.
NO MULLINS EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAM IN SOUTH SAN MATTEO HE'S
GOING AT IT AND WANTS TO BUILD A
FACILITY IN IN THE NOTHING WRONG
WITH A FINANCES ONE DAY LIKE YOU
KNOW WHAT.
THIS IS NOT MY THING WHEN I MOVE
ON TO DO.
YOU KNOW THE A LIFE COACH.
GIVE ME A CAREER IDEAS MISTER
MOM AND DAD AND TO HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT THAT THAT ASSET
REMAINS WHAT IT WAS -- DESTINED
FOR JUST SOME PROTECTION SO
OBVIOUSLY I'M PART OF THIS SO
WANT TO MAKE JUST OUT THE RECORD
THIS ISSUE HAS COME UP AND OTHER
CONVERSATIONS I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE.
STRONG PROTECTIONS THERE.
LET ME JUST SAY I AM LOOKING FOR
A POST LEGISLATIVE CAREER SO I
MAY TAKE YOU UP ON THAT --
SUGGESTION BY -- AND AS A JOINT
AUTHOR I LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT WE HAVE
INCLUDED SOME CLAWBACK
PROVISIONS.
OUGHT TO ENSURE THAT.
THE ENTITIES RECEIVING THE FUNDS
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AS CHILD
CARE CENTER. FOR A SPECIFIED
AMOUNT OF TIME SO I'M VERY
SENSITIVE ON THE ISSUES THAT
YOU'RE RAISING.
AND IF WE NEED ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE TO FURTHER CLARIFY THAT --
OF CERTAINLY MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN THAT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
MISTER MCCARTY THE BUDGET
PROCESS WHERE WE CAN ENSURE THAT
SOME OF THOSE GUARD RAILS ARE IN
PLACE -- WHEN WE WHEN WE
ACTUALLY PUT DOLLARS INTO THIS
NEWLY CREATED FIND?
AND I BELIEVE A WITH EMBEDDED IN
THE BILL AS A TEN YEAR
COMMITMENT.
YES FROM TIME TO RECEIVE THE
MONEY.
YES TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
READY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A SEEING NINE AND WE HAVE A
MOTION.
THEY MOVED.
SECOND THE SECOND -- THE MOTION
IN THE CAN YOU DO YOU DO TAKE
THE AMENDMENTS YES OKAY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS.
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
YOUR PREPARATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE SMITH
SMITH I VOEPEL [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible] THREE VOTES.
THE BILL HAS RESULTED IS ON CALL.
A WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA JUMP
AHEAD A MISS REAVIS WHO WAS NEXT
BECAUSE SHE'S LETTING MISTER
FRAZIER GO FIRST WHICH IS VERY
NICE OF HER MISTER FRAZIER OZER.
HEY COME FOR MISTER FRAZIER YOU
IN THE SUPERINTENDENT.
I WOULD HAVE SAID YES.
SPECIAL BECAUSE MISTER FRAZIER.
BUT EITHER WAY THAT'S A JOB AS A
JOKE BUT EITHER WAY MISTER
FRAZIER HAS -- ELEVEN SEVENTY
TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE MEMBER AS RECOMMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU STAFF
FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL IN.
INPUT.
NON PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE A
DISTINCT KIND OF PRIVATE SCHOOL
THAT SERVES STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES OR HIGH NEEDS.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY TO INSURE THAT.
THESE SPECIALIZED NON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS HAVE THE A PROPERLY
TRAINED STAFF TO EDUCATE AND
CARE FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS.
WILL ALSO GIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
MONITOR AND PROTECT STUDENTS
ACROSS THE NON PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM.
RECENT TRAGIC EVENTS HAVE
EXPOSED THE URGENT NEED FOR THIS
CHANGE.
WE MUST MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
THE STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN AND I
HAVE BROUGHT TOGETHER THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE ALL AGREED
ADDITIONAL MEASURES ONE HENCE
THE SAFETY.
OF OUR STUDENTS.
BETTER ATTENDING THE NON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
COLLABORATION INPUT OF ALL
PARTIES.
AND I HAVE YOUR AS YOU NOTICE --
SOME SUPER TEN PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND -- TO
START THE TEST ME AND ALSO CINDY
SMITH.
WITH THE STATE OF COUNSEL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
[inaudible]
SIR [inaudible] TO FAMOUS CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER FRAZIER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
WE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO THIS BILL IS ABOUT
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
STUDENTS WHO ARE EXCEPTIONAL AND
HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS -- IT IS SAD.
HAVING RECENTLY GONE THROUGH THE
EXPERIENCE OF WORKING WITH A
SCHOOL WHERE STUDENT LOST HIS
LIFE BECAUSE OF BEING RESTRAINED
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS BILL
NOW OUTLINES PROVISIONS.
THAT WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR HOW
WE INTERVENE -- AND HOPEFULLY
PREVENT SIMILAR SITUATIONS FROM
OCCURRING -- IT DOES COMMONSENSE
THINGS LIKE ENSURE THAT THERE
ARE STAFF ON SITE -- WHO HAVE
THE PROPER CREDENTIALS AND KNOW
HOW TO WORK AROUND BEHAVIORAL --
INTERVENTION -- TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF ANY PARTICULAR STUDENT
IT ENSURES THAT THERE ARE IS ON
SITE VISITS IN MONITORING THAT
SHOULD TAKE PLACE.
THAT THE REPORTING OF A SERIOUS
INCIDENT WOULD HAPPEN ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY WITHIN A DAY'S
NOTICE -- IN ITS SPEAKS DIRECTLY
TO HOW REVOCATION OF THE
CERTIFICATE FOR A PROGRAM --
WHERE AN INCIDENT HAS OCCURRED?
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN QUICKLY AS AS
SOMEONE WHO RECENTLY HAD GO TO A
LEGAL COURT BATTLE -- TO MAKE
THAT REVOCATION HAPPENED I CAN
TELL YOU THIS IS A VERY
THOUGHTFUL BILL THAT SPEAKS TO
THE TYPES OF PROVISIONS THAT
WILL BE IMPORTANT.
IN PROTECTING OUR LEARNERS IN
OUR FAMILY SAID NO PARENT SHOULD
EVER HAVE TO HEAR THAT THEY'VE
LOST A CHILD I DO TO OUR
RESTRAINT OR SECLUSION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR A. B..
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YES THANK YOU JUROR O'DONNELL.
PLACE YOUR KILEY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
IT WAS STATED MY NAME IS ANDY
SMITH AND I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR POLICY ON THE CITY
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
THE STATE COUNCIL IS AN
INDEPENDENT STATE AGENCY THAT
ADVOCATES FOR IMPROVEMENTS IN
THE SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER FOR ALL THINGS BILL AND
THINK USES STATE SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION THURMOND FOR
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
WHEN HIS PARENTS SEND THEIR
CHILD TO SCHOOL REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER TO PUBLIC SCHOOL OR
PRIVATE SCHOOL THEY SEND THEIR
CHILD THERE WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT THE CHILD'S GONNA RECEIVE A
QUALITY EDUCATION?
THAT THE CHILD'S GONNA BE
RESPECTED AND THE CHILD'S GOING
TO BE SAFE WE NEED TO LEARN FROM
THE TRAGEDY LAST YEAR THAT LED
TO THE DEATH OF A STUDENT AND
PUT IN PLACE NOW THE NEED
IMPROVEMENTS. FOR OVERSIGHT FOR
ALL SCHOOLS TO ENSURE EVERY
STUDENT IS SAFE.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO PROVIDES
IMPORTANT DITIONS AND
CLARIFICATIONS REGARDING THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES.
IN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE PARENTS
DESPERATELY NEED.
WHEN THE PLACE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND ON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THE STUDENTS ARE SERVING
SOME OF THE STUDENTS KNOW
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS?
IN PARTICULAR THE COUNCIL'S
ESPECIALLY PLEASE OF THE BILL
REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO SERVE
STUDENTS WAS AN AFRICAN BEHAVIOR
CHALLENGES HAVE STAFF ON
EXPERTISE TO IMPLEMENT POSITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTIONS AND
SUPPORTS FOR STUDENTS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE BEHAVIOR IS
A FORM OF COMMUNICATION
ESPECIALLY FOR STUDENTS WERE NON
VERBAL WE'RE ALSO PLEASED TO SEE
THE BILL NOW CAN TRAIN.
HAVE A TRAINING COMPONENT
THEY'LL BE ON FOR ALL STAFF SO
THEY HAVE BETTER SKILLS AND
TOOLS AVAILABLE TO KNOW HOW TO
ACT INTERACT WITH STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
IN THAT SCHOOL MINISTERS WILL
ALSO BE REQUIRED TO HAVE THE
PROPER CREDENTIALS FOR THEIR
POSITIONS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
I GET AFTERNOON JIMMY
TREMENDOUSLY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE'RE AWARE OF RECENT AMENDMENTS
AND WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT HIM
BUT WE'RE STILL IN SUPPORT OF
THE MOMENT.
GET GOOD AFTERNOON THE INJURY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SCHOOLS.
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT AND WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
DANIELLE MAILLET CALIFORNIA
LINES OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES WE ARE ALSO MOVING TO A
SUPPORT AS AMENDED POSITION I
WITH THE RESENTMENT THAT WERE
TAKEN THANK YOU.
ERICA OFTEN ONLY HALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE DID HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS I
THINK THEY WILL TAKE CARE OF OUR
CONCERNS I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT THE LANGUAGE READS.
AND THEN WE CAN HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH STAFF BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THAT.
TOO THANK YOU SEE NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
A SINGLE OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISS
SMITH.
IT'S LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND AND THE SUPERINTENDENT ONCE
AGAIN FOR THIS REALLY IMPORTANT --
PIECE OF CLEAN UP WORK WHICH
REALLY SPEAKS TO THE SAFETY OF
OUR STUDENTS HAVING RECENTLY
SERVED ON A SCHOOL BOARD I KNOW
THERE'S NOTHING MORE IMPACTFUL
THAN THAT DECISION THAT WE MAKE.
TO PLACE ONE OF OUR CHILDREN IN
AN OUTSIDE PLACEMENT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T MEET THEIR NEEDS AND TO
HAVE THIS EXTRA MEASURE OF
CAUTION -- AROUND THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE IN A SAFE AND
APPROPRIATE ENVIRONMENT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT SO I
APPRECIATED I APPRECIATE THEIR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE IT'S
YOU KNOW REALLY SOLID IN A
VIABLE SOLUTION FOR THOSE KIDDOS
THANK YOU.
SING OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
ARE WE A MOTION.
MOVED AND MISTER MCCARTY WILL
SECOND.
MISTER KILEY WAS SECOND I'M
SORRY MR KILEY THE SECOND -- YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST.
WHAT A FANTASTIC OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTNER WITH MY GOOD FRIEND?
MR THURMAN ON HIS PASSION
SUPPORT FOR ALL CHILDREN.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS
IS AN ABSOLUTE NECESSITY TO
CONTINUE THE SUPPORT OF THE
SPECIAL NEEDS COMMUNITY.
AND AS AS OF MENTIONED.
WHEN YOU HAVE A CHILD WITH
BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS?
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE
APPROPRIATELY TRAINED
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE.
TO START THAT PROCESS AND I AM
VERY PROUD TO BE ABLE TO
SPONSORED OR BE BUSINESSES HIM
AS OUR SPONSOR THANK YOU.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOUR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
AYE AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL
WEBER. FOR THE BILL IS FOR VOTED
IS OUT.
WELL NOW MOVES TO MISS REVERSE --
SHE HAS.
FILE ITEM FIVE SEVEN EIGHT FILE
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] TWENTY
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN I HAVE A FIVE
OKAY. FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
HIGHLAND MI [inaudible]
SIX ME [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING ALL OF THE COMMITTEES
CLEAR FINE AMENDMENTS AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK STAFF FOR THEIR
EFFORTS TO BUILD UPON THE
EXISTING -- PROPOSAL.
I'M AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
ESTABLISHES A SCHOOL PAVEMENT TO
PARKS GRANT PROGRAM ADMINISTERED
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO PROVIDE APPLYING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FUNDING FOR
CONVERTING PORTIONS OF EXISTING
PAVEMENT.
ON SCHOOL GROUNDS TO LIVE IN
SCHOOL YARDS AND GARDENS.
PARTICIPATING SCHOOLS WE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT AN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM THAT
INCORPORATE INCORPORATES SCIENCE
MATH LITERACY IN NUTRITION FOR
THEIR STUDENTS.
OUR SCHOOLS WILL BE REQUIRED TO
PARTNER WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO MATCH STATE
GRANT MONEY.
PRIORITY WILL BE GIVEN TO
SCHOOLS WITH POOR AIR QUALITY
AND HIGH AMOUNTS OF STUDENTS ON
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH.
THE ANALYSIS QUESTIONS.
WHY WE CALL THIS BILL PAVEMENT
TO PARKS THE QUICK ANSWER IS AT
A DISTRICT SCHOOL THAT I VISITED
IN LOS ANGELES?
OF THE KIDS ASTOR TEACHER IF
THEY COULD GO TO THE PARK WHICH
WAS ACTUALLY ON THEIR SCHOOL
GARDEN BOXES AND FOR MANY OF
THESE KIDS THIS IS THE ONLY
ACCESS THEY HAVE TO GREEN SPACE
SINCE THEY LIVE.
IN APARTMENT BUILDINGS AND
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE ACCESS --
TO PARKS NEAR NEARBY.
I'M YOU KNOW IN THE MINDS OF
THESE KIDS THEY WERE THIS IS
WHERE THEY GO TO THE PARK EVERY
DAY AND THEY SPEND MOST OF THEIR
DAY AT SCHOOL -- AND SO THIS IS
THE ACCESS THAT THEY HAVE OF
POOR AIR QUALITY IMPACTS
NUMEROUS COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
I'M IN LOS ANGELES ALONE THERE
ARE -- WHAT?
OVER ONE POINT SIX MILLION LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO HEALTH ISSUES DUE
TO POOR AIR QUALITY.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY BY
THE PROCEEDINGS OF THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES.
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINO
MINORITIES BERIT
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN FROM THE
AIR POLLUTION BECAUSE MAINLY BY
NON HISPANIC WHITES.
THIS RECENTLY PUBLISHED RESEARCH
QUALIFIES FOR THE FIRST TIME THE
RACIAL GAP BETWEEN WHO CAUSES
AIR POLLUTION IN WHO BREED SAID.
THE DATA INDICATE THAT EVEN
THOUGH MINORITIES ARE CONTINUE
CONTRIBUTING LESS TO THE OVERALL
ISSUE OF AIR POLLUTION THERE
AFFECTED BY IT MORE.
THE CITY PROJECT ALSO COMPLETED
A STUDY WHICH HIGHLIGHTS THE
CHILDREN OF COLOR.
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY LIVING
COMMUNITIES OF CONCENTRATED
POVERTY WITHOUT ENOUGH PLACES TO
PLAY AND PARKS AND SCHOOLS AND
WITHOUT ACCESS TO CARS -- AN
ADEQUATE TRANSIT SYSTEM TO REACH
QUALITY PARKS AND SCHOOL FIELDS
ANOTHER NEIGHBORHOODS.
ON A NATIONWIDE BASIS LAST YEAR
40% OF LATINO CHILDREN AND 39%
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN CAN CHILDREN
AND URBAN AREAS WERE KEPT INSIDE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
THERE NEIGHBORHOODS.
WERE PERCEIVED AS DANGEROUS
COMPARED 225% OF NON HISPANIC
WHITE CHILDREN.
UP FINALLY ACCORDING TO A RECENT
PRESS RELEASE ISSUED BY THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AS PART OF THEIR STRIKE
NEGOTIATIONS.
WITH THE TEACHERS UNION THE
DISTRICT WILL BE ESTABLISHING A
JOINT GREEN SPACE TASK FORCE
CHARGED WITH PRESENTING A PLAN
TO INCREASE GREENSPACE AND
COMMUNITY SCHOOL PARKS BY
DECEMBER -- TWENTY NINETEEN
EXPERTS TEACHERS AND PARENTS ALL
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROVIDING CHILDREN WITH ACCESS
TO PARKS AND GREEN SPACES.
OF THE THIS PAYMENTS TO PARKS
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN
TO IMPROVE PHYSICAL FITNESS
SUPPORT CREATIVITY REDUCE
VIOLENCE CYMBELINE REDUCE STRESS
INSPIRE CRITICAL THINKING AND
PROBLEM SOLVING.
AND INCREASE COMPETENCY AND
SCIENCE LANGUAGE AND LITERACY.
I HAVE ME TODAY -- RICO MUST AN
AUTO WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LANDS AND ALSO READ A DIS TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF TESTIMONY THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RECALL MONSTER TO NOT --
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND --
REALLY WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND HAS BEEN
CONVERTING SCHOOLYARDS.
IN THE UNITED STATES FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS AND IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IDEA AND
ADVANCE THIS IN CALIFORNIA FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS WE ARE PARK
POOR.
WE HAVE OVER ALMOST TWO MILLION
KIDS IN LOS ANGELES ALONE THAT
ARE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A PARK.
THE SAME COULD BE SAID ABOUT
ANAHEIM BAKERSFIELD FRESNO THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON IF YOU'RE
PARK POOR YOU'RE ALSO NOT READY
FOR THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THAT MEANS NO TREE CANOPY THAT
MEANS SUSCEPTIBILITY TO FLOAT
SEVERE FLOODING IN THE IMPACTS
OF THAT BECAUSE OF LACK OF
PERMEABLE PAVING.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- MENTIONED
OR NOTED THAT FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF KIDS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THIS IS THEIR ONLY
OPPORTUNITY TO BE OUTSIDE.
THEIR OWN NEIGHBORHOOD IS EITHER
AND ACCESSIBLE BECAUSE THEY'RE
IN APARTMENTS OR IT'S TOO
DANGEROUS FRANKLY TO BE OUTSIDE.
AND IF YOU CAN'T GO OUTSIDE
BECAUSE IT'S TOO HOT BECAUSE
THERE'S NO WHERE TO PLAY OR A
BECAUSE THERE'S NO SHADE -- IT
REALLY LEADS -- TO INESCAPABLE
SITUATION FOR KIDS NOT TO HAVE
ANY RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
WHATSOEVER WE'VE CONVERTED OVER
TWO HUNDRED PLAYGROUNDS IN NEW
YORK CITY -- SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY IT'S RESULTED IN FOUR
POINT ONE MILLION PEOPLE HAVING
MORE ACCESS TO PARKS YOU CAN DO
THIS THROUGH SCHOOL YARDS YOU
CAN HAVE JOINT USE AGREEMENTS --
SO THAT THE SCHOOL YARDS ARE
AVAILABLE AFTER SCHOOL AND ON
WEEKENDS TO THE PUBLIC ALL OF
THIS CAN BE DONE.
AND THIS IS OF INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IDEA I REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR ANNA URGENTLY
VOTE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS READ
**** EXCUSE ME READ ADDIS ON
BEHALF OF THE LA NEIGHBORHOOD
LAND TRUST HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY.
VERY IMPORTANT TO DEAL WE HAVE --
BASIC LACK OF GREEN SPACE PARKS
AND GARDENS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THE ONLY NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST
IS A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION WE OPERATE OUT OF
LA COUNTY.
AND DAY IN AND DAY OUT WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH THIS ISSUE.
EVEN WHEN YOU PUT -- AS THE
STATE HAS DONE PROP SIXTY EIGHT
POINTS IN PUBLIC RESOURCES ON
THE TABLE.
OR AS IN LA COUNTY MEASURE A
RECENTLY PASSED AND LOCAL --
DOLLARS ON THE TABLE IT'S NOT
ALWAYS ABOUT THE MONEY.
IT'S ABOUT TRYING TO FIND SPACES
THAT ARE EITHER AFFORDABLE OR
EVEN AVAILABLE AT ALL.
AND SO WHAT WE SEE IN A BILL
LIKE THIS IS IT ALLOWS US TO
ACCESS NEW RESOURCES IN THIS
CASE.
ASPHALT SPACES AT SCHOOLS.
WHICH SERVE THAT FUNCTION OF
PROVIDING OPEN SPACE GREEN SPACE
GARDENS OR A SMALL POCKET PARK.
SO IT'S CRITICAL THAT A MEASURE
LIKE THIS MOVE FORWARD IT HELPS
THE COMMUNITIES NOT JUST IN LA
I'M SURE WITH YOU ALL GO BACK TO
YOUR DISTRICT YOU HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEM WHEN YOU GO BACK.
THE PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING.
TO TAKE THE FUNDING THAT THEY
CAN GET FROM THE STATE THEN GO
FIND HOW TO USE THAT FUNDING HOW
TO FIND SPACES TO BUY TO ACQUIRE
IN BILL PARKS.
A BILL LIKE THIS ALLOWS US TO
CLOSE THAT GAP ALLOWS A STAKE IN
A FIGHT -- SPACES -- WE'RE WE
CAN PROVIDE THAT -- TYPE OF PARK
FOR THE TYPE TO COMMUNITIES WERE
LOOKING AT LA NEIGHBORHOOD
LANCHESTER REALLY DOES TRY TO
FOCUS ON THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES -- THAT ARE
DESPERATELY TRYING TO GET ACCESS
TO THESE FACILITIES THERE'S TWO
NUMBERS ARE CLOSER TO NUMBERS.
THAT I WANT TO SHARE.
THE STANDARD IS TO BE ABLE TO GO
ACCESS A PARK OR GREEN SPACE
WITHIN A TEN MINUTE WALK FROM
YOUR HOME.
IN LA COUNTY ALONE ONLY ABOUT
50% OF THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE
ABLE TO DO THAT SO WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO THIS MEASURE
REALLY HELPS US THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT.
KEVIN FROM OF THE COMP UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
SCHOOL EDUCATORS AND SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- ANY ANY.
OPPOSITION.
SINGLE OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MISTER CARTY YES THAT THANK YOU
I I THINK THIS IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED DIED I PROBABLY DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF THIS IN MY
DISTRICT BUT I KNOW.
THE DENSITY YOU HAVE IN YOUR
DISTRICT IN THE VALLEY PARKWAY
MEN RIGHT FAMILY IN SANTA ANA I
SEE THIS FIRST HAND WITH THESE.
COMMUNITIES WITH SO MANY MULTI
FAMILY APARTMENTS AND THERE'S NO
PLACE TO GO WHETHER THE YEAR ON
YOUR SCHOOL DAY OR ON WEEKENDS
AND EVENINGS AND HOLIDAYS.
THIS IS NEEDED OBVIOUSLY AT THE
SCHOOL SITES BUT I THINK BIGGER
THAN THAT LIKE.
YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR WITNESS --
IN THESE -- PARK DEFICIENT
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE THEY DON'T
HAVE A PARK ALL OF THE GREEN
SPACE BUT THERE'S A SCHOOL.
AND SOMETIMES LOCKED UP I KNOW
THAT'S FOR SECURITY REASONS AND
SAFETY WANT TO PROTECT OUR ASSET
AND ALL THAT BUT THE SAME TIME.
WE'RE DEALING WITH OTHER ISSUES
AS WELL SO I THINK WE NEED TO TO
STEP IT UP AND AND JUST -- ONE
OBSERVATION IS THAT WE DO HAVE
OUR PARK BONDS EVERY EVERY EVERY
FEW YEARS AND SO I THINK THIS TO
BE AN EXCELLENT.
PROGRAM TO BE INCLUDED AS WELL I
KNOW YOU'RE IN THE END COMMITTEE
TRYING TO CREATE THIS PROGRAM.
BUT HAVE THE CONCLUSION OF THIS
IN THE NEXT PARK BOND THAT GOES
ON THE BALLOT IS PROBABLY.
A GOOD PATH AS WELL SO.
THANK YOU.
I MISS SMITH.
THANK YOU MEMORY OF US FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE I'M I'M
COMPLETELY INCLINED TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT MEAN WE'VE
I'M SURE YOU KNOW THE TIE INS
PARTICULARLY WHEN KIDS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO PLANT SOMETHING
AND SEE IF GROWING THAT TIES IN
SO BEAUTIFULLY WITH THE NEXT
GENERATION SCIENCE STANDARDS MY
BIGGEST CONCERN NOW.
IS THAT WE ARE ALLOWING SCHOOLS
AS OPPORTUNITY WITH WHAT ARE ONE
TIME DOLLARS AND I I KNOW THAT
WE GOT TO THIS PLACE IN YOUR
DISTRICT DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
BECAUSE IT CONSISTENTLY AGAIN WE
NEED TO KEEP REMINDING OUR
PUBLIC OF THIS WE RANK IN PER
PUPIL SPENDING IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE BOTTOM.
TEN PERSISTENTLY AND SO SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SCHOOL BOARDS HAVE
MADE THE CHOICE TO REMOVE GREEN
SPACE FROM THEIR CAMPUSES BASED
ON THE ONGOING MAINTENANCE COSTS
SIMPLY OF HAVING THOSE SPACES
WITH THE IRRIGATION AND WITH
MAINTENANCE CREWS.
REQUIRED FOR OUR CHILDREN TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT KIND OF SPACE
TO ENJOY SO WHILE I ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THIS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE IT
FORWARD WE GOT TO START TO
INCLUDE THIS NOW IN OUR BIGGER
CONVERSATION OF OUR SCHOOLS
BEING UNDER FUNDED ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE POINT THANK YOU I SEE NO
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS -- TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE -- THANK YOU AB SEVEN
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WILL BRING
NATURE TO CHILDREN AND MUCH
NEEDED COMMUNITIES -- BY
CREATING THE SCHOOL PAVEMENTS
PARKS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK OF THE WE
DON'T HAVE MOTION A MISS MISS
SMITH MR MCCARTY.
MOVED AND SECONDED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I KILEY KILEY AYE
KALRA MCCARTY.
THE EYES SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL
WEBER. FOR THE LAST FOUR VOTE SO
IT IS UP.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE'RE YEAH.
YEAH YEAH YEAH I'M BACK I'M
GONNA HAND THIS OVER TO MISS
SMITH THEN
.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER KILEY
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO SORRY THIS
IS MAKING THEIR WAY UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AT SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO
I'D LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE STUDENT
SAFETY AND CALIFORNIA'S K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS BY REQUIRING EACH
SCHOOL SAFETY PLAN TO INCLUDE A
TARGETED VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PLAN ESTABLISHING A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY THREAT ASSESSMENT
TEAM.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES SCHOOL
SAFETY PLANS TO THE EXTENT
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE TO
INCLUDE POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
PROCEDURES AIMED AT THE
PREVENTION OF BULLYING AND TO
INCLUDE CLEAR GUIDELINES FOR THE
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
FOLLOWING A NUMBER OF TRAGIC
SCHOOL ATTACKS SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE PARENTS AND STUDENTS
ARE MORE CONCERNED THAN EVER
ABOUT SCHOOL SAFETY.
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
THREATS MADE BY STUDENTS ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES MOST OF A
TRANSIENT AND HARMLESS NATURE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO QUICKLY
DISTINGUISH WHICH THREATS ARE
SUBSTANTIVE THREATS.
POSING A CONTINUING RISK OF
DANGER TO OTHERS.
THE FBI AND THE SECRET SERVICE
NATIONAL THREAT ASSESSMENT
CENTER OR NTAC HAVE FOUND THE
PERPETRATORS OF SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
CHAU OBSERVABLE WARNING SIGNS
THAT IT ACTED UPON.
MAY HAVE PREVENTED THE VIOLENT
ACT.
SUCH STUDENTS WERE OFTEN VICTIMS
OF BULLYING WHO WOULD BECOME
ANGRY AND DEPRESSED AND WERE
INFLUENCED BY A VARIETY OF
SOCIAL FAMILIAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL FACTORS HOWEVER.
BECAUSE MANY OF THOSE WARNING
SIGNS CAN BE FOUND IN SO MANY
STUDENTS IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO
DEVELOP ANY SORT OF PROFILING
CHECKLISTS.
THEREFORE BOTH THE FBI IN NTAC
INSTEAD RECOMMENDED SCHOOLS
ADOPT A THREAT ASSESSMENT
APPROACH TO PREVENT TARGETED
ACTS OF VIOLENCE.
THEY ALSO THAT RECOMMEND BEST
PRACTICES THAT INCLUDE
DEVELOPING A CENTRAL REPORTING
MECHANISM FOR SUSPICIOUS
BEHAVIORS ENSURING INFORMATION
IS PROMPTLY EVALUATED BY A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM.
AND ENDING THE PRACTICE OF ZERO
TOLERANCE PROCESS SEES THAT CAN
FURTHER ISOLATE THE INDIVIDUAL.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
REQUIRING EACH COMPREHENSIVE
SCHOOL SAFETY PLAN TO INCLUDE A
TARGETED VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PLAN.
ESTABLISHING A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY THREAT ASSESSMENT
TEAM OF SCHOOL PERSONNEL WHO
DIRECT MANAGE AND DOCUMENT THE
THREAT ASSESSMENT PROCESS.
I HAVE WITH ME THIS AFTERNOON
VERSE PEARSON THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY ABOUT RADO COUNTY AND
MICHELLE TO STIR WHO IS A SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE CONCERNED I
AM A HIGHLY TRAINED PASSIONATE
NATIONALLY CERTIFIED SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST OVER THE PAST
FOURTEEN YEARS I'VE WORKED IN
FOUR STATES AND IN JUST ABOUT
EVERY TYPE OF SCHOOL SYSTEM YOU
CAN IMAGINE.
I'M HERE TODAY REQUESTING YOUR
VOTE ON AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO
I UNDERSTAND THERE IS OPPOSITION
GIVING CONSIDERATION OF PRIVACY
LAWS AND THE POTENTIAL FOR
OPENING THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
YET THESE CONCERNS ARE THE
ANTITHESIS OF WHAT FIELD BASED
RESEARCH AND PRACTICE HAVE SHOWN
US.
IMPLEMENTING START ASSESSMENTS
IS AN EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE
FOR PREVENTING ACTS OF VIOLENCE
IN SCHOOLS FURTHER MORE IT OPENS
PATHWAYS FOR INTERVENTION
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING AND
PROVIDING SAFETY NETS FOR
STUDENTS WHO OTHERWISE MAY FEEL
ISOLATED.
AND HOPELESS WHICH ARE KEY
PRECURSORS TO VIOLENT BEHAVIOR.
SCHOOLS WOULD IMPLEMENT THREAT
ASSESSMENT PROTOCOLS HAVE
STUDENTS AND STAFF WHO ARE
TRAINED ON WHAT'S A REPORT.
WHERE TO REPORT AND AND WHEN TO
REPORT AND THIS IS KEY SCHOOLS
THAT IMPLEMENT THREAT ASSESSMENT
PROTOCOLS KNOW HOW TO RESPOND?
OVER THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
RESEARCH HAS REVEALED THAT AND
SEVEN OUT OF TEN ACTS OF GUN
VIOLENCE IN AND FOUR OUT OF FIVE
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
THE ATTACKER HAD TOLD PEOPLE OF
HIS PLANS AHEAD OF TIME WE KNOW
THAT IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CASES PEOPLE AT RISK OF HURTING
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS SHOW SIGNS
AND SIGNALS BEFORE THE ACT OF
VIOLENCE TAKES PLACE.
AND LET ME BE CLEAR THE TYPES OF
THREAT REQUIRING INTERVENTION GO
WELL BEYOND THE PROSPECT OF A
MASS SHOOTING.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN STUDENTS
AGES TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN
EXPERIENCED A RATE OF THIRTY
THREE VICTIMIZATION PER ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
THIS STATISTIC IS NOT THE NUMBER
OF THREATS MADE BUT ACTUATED
VIOLENCE THAT OCCURRED IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT TO LOOK
FOR IT CAN BE EASY TO DISMISS
THE SIGNS AND MORE OFTEN THE
CASE IN OUR SCHOOLS WHEN YOU SEE
THE SIGNS?
BUT DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT
IT WELL THE CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
CAN BE TRAGIC.
WE KNOW THAT THREAT ASSESSMENTS
WORK WE CAN LOOK TO OUR
COLLEAGUES IN LOS ANGELES ALL
THE WAY TO GLENN COUNTY.
AND MANY OTHERS IN BETWEEN SAN
MATTEO SANTA CRUZ SAN DIEGO AS
WELL AS NUMEROUS OTHERS HAVE
CHOSEN TO IMPLEMENT THREAD
ASSESSMENT PROTOCOLS WITH MULTI
DISCIPLINARY COALITIONS.
AND THEY ARE EXPERIENCING
SUCCESS THEIR ACTIONS HAVE
PROTECTED AND IN RICH LIVES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS VERNE PEARSON I'M
THAT ELECTED DISTRICT ATTORNEY
IN EL DORADO COUNTY HAVE BEEN A
PROSECUTOR FOR TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS.
BOTH AS A DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND DEPUTY DA AND AND
ELECTED THE A THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS -- TWENTY YEARS AGO THIS
PAST SATURDAY. TO ADD YOUNG MAN
WENT INTO COLUMBINE HIGH SCHOOL --
LOADED TO AND PREPARED TO KILL I
NEVER OF THEIR OF FELLOW
CLASSMATES AT NOON ONE YEAR AGO
ALMOST EXACTLY ONE YEAR AGO THE
NEARLY ST VERY SIMILAR SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES HER.
OCCURRED IN PARKLAND FLORIDA.
NGUYEN THE THE CASE THE SHOOTER
ENTERED PARKLAND FLORIDA THE
FIRST ADULT THAT CAME IN CONTACT
WITH THEM WAS A SCHOOL MONITOR.
THE SCHOOL MONITOR IMMEDIATELY
RECOGNIZED THIS BOY NOT BY HIS
NAME BUT AS THAT IN AIR QUOTES
CRAZY KID WHO WAS VOTED MOST
LIKELY BY THE FACULTY TO SHOOT
AT THE SCHOOL.
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE THAT TWENTY
YEARS LATER WE HAVEN'T
COLLECTIVELY.
LEARNED THAT THERE IS BEHAVIORS
THAT CAN BE READILY IDENTIFIED
THAT.
VEAL THAT SOMEONE MAY BE ON THE
PATHWAY TO VIOLENCE SUCH AS THIS.
UPS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA MUCH
LIKE THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES.
THIS THREAD ASSESSMENT
APPROACHED.
HAS BEEN INCREASINGLY
IMPLEMENTED IN VARIOUS --
JURISDICTIONS WHAT SEVENTEEN
TWENTY TWO DOES AND THE WAY IT'S
DRAFTED IS TO TRY TO TO ENABLE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY TO SET FORTH A
STANDARDIZED PROTOCOL NOT THE
SPECIFIC DETAILS OF HOW IT'LL BE
IMPLEMENTED AN INDIVIDUAL
JURISDICTION.
BUT A VERY SPECIFIC YOU NEED TO
PLAN TO DO THIS AND YOU NEED TO
USE EVIDENCE BASED.
BEST PRACTICES WHICH A LOOK TO
BEHAVIORS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED --
WELL IN ADVANCE.
WE IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT WAIT
UNTIL THERE'S ANOTHER HOT HOT
HIGH PROFILE INCIDENT TO TAKE
PLACE BEFORE WE TAKE ACTION ON
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I WOULD
DEFER BACK.
TO THANK YOU ANY SPEAKERS IN
KEEP THE INJURY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS ANY ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
HE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M FIRST LET ME THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF ON A AND
THE SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO MEET AND
TALK TO US ABOUT OUR CONCERNS --
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T BELIEVE
WE'RE YET AT THE POINT OF HAVING
REACHED AGREEMENT ON WHAT WOULD
BE NEEDED IN THIS LEGISLATION TO
ALLOW SCHOOLS TO EFFECTIVELY
ASSESS THREATS.
WHILE ENSURING EQUITY AND
PROTECTING STUDENTS RIGHTS.
WE ALL AGREE ON THE GOAL OF
SAFER SCHOOLS AND THAT WE SHOULD
WORK TO PREVENT VIOLENT
INCIDENTS RATHER THAN JUST
REACTING WHEN THEY OCCUR.
WELL THE USE OF THREAT
ASSESSMENTS TWO TEAMS TO ASSESS
AND RESPOND TO POTENTIAL THREATS
OF VIOLENCE CAN BE EFFECTIVE IN
PREVENTING SCHOOL VIOLENCE AND
CAN BE DONE IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS STUDENT RIGHTS.
THE DEVIL IS IN THE DETAILS.
WHEN THREAT ASSESSMENT TEAMS DO
NOT HAVE ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
AND INSTEAD HAVE AN OVER
REPRESENTATION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL?
AND WHEN THE STATUTORY FRAMEWORK
FOR THREAT ASSESSMENT PROCEDURES
DOES NOT EXPLICITLY PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENT RIGHTS.
IT IS ALL TOO EASY FOR THE WORK
OF A THREAT ASSESSMENT TEAM TO
BECOME ONE MORE WAY THAT PUSHES
STUDENTS OUT OF SCHOOL AND INTO
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
RATHER THAN PROVIDING WITH THEM
WITH THE SUPPORT AND SERVICES
THEY NEED.
SCHOOL CLIMATE CAN BE HARMED IF
STUDENTS FEEL THEY MAY BE
UNFAIRLY TARGETED FOR DISCIPLINE
OR EVEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERVENTION ON THE BASIS OF
ANONYMOUS REPORTS.
WITHOUT ADEQUATE SAFEGUARDS THE
OUTCOMES OF THE THREAT
ASSESSMENTS WILL LIKELY HAVE A
DISPARATE IMPACT ON STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS TODAY WE KNOW THAT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES STAFFING
IS WOEFULLY INADEQUATE.
MANY SCHOOLS HAVE A SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER BUT NOPE
COUNSELORS WHATSOEVER.
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT AND
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE LACK OF
EXPLICIT PROTECTIONS IN THE
LANGUAGE OF AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
TWO THE THREAT ASSESSMENT TEAMS
REQUIRED UNDER THE BILL WILL ALL
TOO LIKELY HAVE AN OVERALL
HARMFUL EFFECT ON SCHOOL CLIMATE.
AS A STARTING POINT WE BELIEVE
THAT ANY LEGISLATION REQUIRING
THREAT ASSESSMENT TEAMS MUST
HAVE CERTAIN SPECIFIC
PROTECTIONS SET OUT IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL.
MOST THREATS ARE STE TRANSIENT
AND THE THREAT ASSESSMENT
PROCEDURES SHOULD HAVE THE GOAL
OF KEEPING STUDENTS IN SCHOOL
WHENEVER POSSIBLE.
PEARLS TO THREAD ASSESSMENT
TEAMS SHOULD ONLY OCCUR WHEN
THERE IS A REASONABLE BASIS TO
CONCLUDE THAT THE STUDENT HAS
ENGAGED IN CONDUCT THAT
INDICATES A THREAT.
THE STUDENT AND STUDENTS PARENTS
SHOULD RECEIVE WRITTEN NOTICE
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF A
REFERRAL TO A THREAT ASSESSMENT
TEAM.
PROTECTIONS MUST BE PUT IN PLACE
TO ENSURE THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
RECORDS IS PROTECTED IN
ACCORDANCE WITH EXISTING LAW AND
REPORTS AND EVALUATIONS FROM THE
THREAT ASSESSMENT TEAM SHOULD
NOT BECOME PART OF THE STUDENTS
DISCIPLINARY RECORD. FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES THE
STUDENT'S I EP TEAM SHOULD BE
CONVENE TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
BEHAVIOR WAS A MANIFESTATION OF
THE STUDENTS DISABILITY.
FINALLY LEGISLATION SHOULD
REQUIRE REPORTING ON A NUMBER OF
FACTORS BY EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT
INCLUDING WHO IS ON THE THREAT
ASSESSMENT TEAM HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE REFERRED FOR
ASSESSMENTS AND THE OUTCOMES OF
THE ASSESSMENTS -- THESE DATA
SHOULD BE REVIEWED PRAYER
PERIODICALLY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THERE HAS BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
CERTAIN STUDENT GROUPS.
THERE ARE GOOD MODELS OUT THERE
AS TO HOW THE WORK SHOULD BE
DONE THE VIRGINIA STUDENT THREAT
ASSESSMENT GUIDELINES WHICH ARE
AT THE BELIEVE MENTIONED IN THE
AUTHOR'S FACT SHEET -- HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO REDUCE RESULT IN FEWER
SUSPENSIONS AND LESSEN
DISPARITIES IN SUSPENSION RATES --
THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF ESSENTIAL
FEATURES THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
THOSE RESULTS THEY DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN TRANSIENT AND
SUBSTITUTED THREATS THEY
EMPHASIZE A FLEXIBLE NON
PUNITIVE APPROACH THAT
DISCOURAGES EXCLUSIONARY
DISCIPLINE IN MOST CASES.
AND THEY REQUIRE STANDARDIZED
RESEARCH PROVEN STRAINING FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THE THREAT
ASSESSMENT TEAMS.
IF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO PUT IN
PLACE REQUIREMENTS FOR THREAT
ASSESSMENT PROCEDURES IN AT
SCHOOL IT NEEDS TO EXERCISE THE
UTMOST CARE TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROCEDURES ACTUALLY BENEFIT
SCHOOL SEVEN SAFETY AND PROTECT
STUDENTS RIGHTS.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO IN ITS
CURRENT FORM HAS THE NECESSARY
PROTECTIONS TO MEET THOSE GOALS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NOSE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
I MOVED TO BILL PLEASE.
NO THE COMMONS MR KILEY WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE.
UP OUTSIDE YEAH [inaudible]
SORRY.
YES I I DID HAVE A SOME
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR MAYBE
YOUR TEAM SO.
I AM I'M.
A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ABOUT THE
THE ISSUES OUTLINED BY BY THE
SEA WITH A SEAL YOU AS YOU KNOW
WE HAD THIS DEBATE IN COMMITTEE
TWO WEEKS AGO WITH MR CHAN'S
BILL ON MORE SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS AND CONVERSELY THE NEED
FOR COUNSELORS AS WELL I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE SAYING.
NOT EITHER OR BUT I I AM
CONCERNED THAT THAT WOULD BE.
THE REMEDY AND FOR ONE YOU KNOW
DISTRICTS ARE STRAPPED THERE'S
NO FUNDING SOURCE TO GUARANTEE
THAT.
AND INTO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE AS MANY SCHOOL
COUNSELORS PSYCHOLOGISTS MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
ON CAMPUS AS WELL SO ONE IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS THAT -- THIS
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO IS
THAT YOU KNOW.
I I HEAR YOUR EXAMPLE IN
COLUMBINE BUT THE TRAGEDY IN
FLORIDA WE HAD A SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER AND UNFORTUNATELY.
IT DIDN'T HELP THE SITUATION --
SO IT'S NOT ALWAYS A GUARANTEE
AND THEN I GUESS THE THIRD THING
SO IF ONE OF THE FIRST THING
THIS THE THIRD THEY RESPOND TO
IS AND THEN ALSO TALKED ABOUT
HER THE LETTER.
THAT THERE WAS A BILL LAST YEAR
THAT WE VOTED ON AND APPROVED
WHICH TALKS ABOUT SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS TO RODRIGUEZ HIS PROPOSAL
AND HOW THIS.
COMPLIMENTS THAT ARE POTENTIALLY --
IS DUPLICATIVE SO.
GO IT'S OKAY WITH YOU CAN I GET
MY WITH THIS A CHANCE DANCER
THAT HAPPY TO ADDRESS AS WELL.
AND THANK OU FOR THE QUESTIONS
I THINK THERE -- VERY IMPORTANT
ONCE A AND AS FOR THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE THE ACLU
REPRESENTATIVE AND AND I HAVE
MET WITH HER AND DISCUSS STATE
AND I SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS IN
TERMS OF PRIVACY IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING IT UNDER THE
USING THE BEST PRACTICES.
BUT THE SPECIFICALLY AS THE
PARKLAND AND AND SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER THAT -- WAS ON CAMPUS --
PRIOR TO PARKLAND TAKING PLACE.
FLORIDA DID NOT HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH A SET OF
STANDARDS THAT USE BEST
PRACTICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
YEAH I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH YOU
FOLLOW IN TERMS OF PARKLAND BUT
AT ALL I WAS VERY DISTURBED WHEN
I READ THE FULL REPORT AND I'VE
DONE A COUPLE PRESENTATIONS ON
IT.
NOT ONLY DID THE SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER HAVE INFORMATION IN ITS
POSSESSION THAT WOULD HAVE WAS
IT WHERE THEY'RE A THREAT
MANAGEMENT TEAM SUCH A CORPORATE
TALKING ABOUT.
IN ALL HE HAD A INFORMATION THAT
WAS REQUESTED BY COUNSELOR ON
CAMPUS -- ABOUT THE STUDENT AND
HE REFUSED TO RELEASE THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE HE WAS
CONCERNED THAT IT WAS LAW
ENFORCEMENT SENSITIVE.
AND HE WOULDN'T REALLY SAID HE
HAD NOT BEEN PROPERLY TRAINED --
AND IN THE LIST GOES ON AND ON
AND ON THE PROBLEM WITH IT.
LET ME GIVE ME ONE OF THE WORST
ONES I DON'T KNOW BURKE MOST THE
PUBLIC IS UNAWARE.
THAT THE FIRST PEOPLE THIS IS --
PARK WHEN DID LOCATION THAT HIGH
SCHOOL IS ACTUALLY IN BROWARD
COUNTY IT WAS A BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPUTY WHO IS A SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER.
THE FIRST POLICE OFFICERS THAT
ENTERED THAT CAMPUS AFTER THE
SHOOTING BEGAN -- WERE FROM
CORAL SPRINGS A NEIGHBORING
JURISDICTION THAT WOULD NOT WAIT
THAT IS THE STANDARD PRACTICE
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO ENTER IN
BROWARD COUNTY BECAUSE OF THE
DYSFUNCTION NOW THAT HE WITH AND
THAT SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
DID NOT PROPERLY HANDLE THAT
SITUATION THE BILL LAST YEAR
READ RODRIGUEZ IS A VERY GOOD
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
IT'S A VERY GOOD BILL.
BUT THROUGHOUT MY CAREER TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OF DOING THIS WHAT I
HAVE SEEN OVER AND OVER AGAIN IS
WE REACT TO THINGS AFTER THE THE
CRISIS AS A BEGUN -- AFTER THE
FIRST SHOT HAS BEEN FIRED WITH
THIS APPROACH IS IS TO TAKE IT
BACK AND MOVE THE TIMELINE BACK
AND TRY TO INTERCEDE BEFORE IT
EVER GETS TO THAT POINT -- AIMED
AT RODRIGUEZ IS BILL OUT OF ALL
THE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AGAIN
IT GOES TO WHAT DO YOU DO AFTER
THE FIRST SHOT HAS BEEN FIRED --
THE IMPORTANT THING I THINK BE A
BOB EVERYTHING ELSE IS
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ADOPT A
STANDARD ONE THAT WE CAN WORK
OUT THAT AT RENT RECONCILES
PRIVACY CONCERNS WHAT GOES IN A
CHILD'S ACUMEN FILE ALL OF THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS.
BUT THAT IT'S A STANDARD THAT
EVERY COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA CAN
LOOK AT AND SAY THESE ARE THE
BEST PRACTICES.
THIS IS THE WAY WE SHOULD DO IT
AND COUNTIES ARE NOT LEFT TO
THEMSELVES TO DO THIS ON AN AD
HOC BASIS THE WAY THEY THINK THE
BASS.
AND I'M I'M VERY MUCH FOR
COUNTIES BEING ABLE TO MAKE
THOSE TYPES OF DECISIONS BUT IF
THEY'RE NOT FOLLOWING THE BEST
PRACTICES THEN THEY'RE NOT DOING
IT PROPERLY.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS THE QUESTION.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE SOME SOME
BACKGROUND FROM A SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS -- POSITION SO
WHEN I STARTED MY CAREER IT WAS
OUTSIDE OF BALTIMORE.
IN MARYLAND AND I WORKED IN AN
ALTERNATIVE EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT HAD VERY AT RISK YOUTH.
AND I WAS TRAINED IN MY SECOND
YEAR OUT ON HOW TO BE A PART OF
A MULTI DISCIPLINARY THREAT
ASSESSMENT TEAM AND I EXECUTED
THREAT ASSESSMENTS -- WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT.
THERE IS A THRESHOLD FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVOLVEMENT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS NOT.
THAT THE EMPHASIS BEING ON THE
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT PIECE OF ME
IS SECONDARY TO THE EMPHASIS IN
TRAINING EDUCATORS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND AND PROVIDING --
DIRECTION ON WHAT YOU DO
WHENEVER YOU HAVE AS A CREDIBLE
THREAT AND SPEAKING AGAIN AS
SOMEBODY WHO IS IN YOUR SCHOOLS
AND THE LAST SEVEN YEARS.
I I CAN SPEAK.
TO ME UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE PUSH
BACK HAS BEEN BECAUSE THERE IS
NOT DIRECTION FOR ADMINISTRATORS
ON WHAT TO DO.
AND IT AND AGAIN ONE PERSON --
BUT VERY PASSIOATE ABOUT BEING
PROACTIVE ON THIS TOPIC AND AND
DO A CORNELL'S RESEARCH OUT OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA IS IS
BY FAR THE THE THE DIRECTION
THAT THAT WE NEED.
TO ADD HERE.
TOO RIGHT SO I THINK VERY
SPECIFICALLY MISTER COLLEY TO
YOU TO YOUR WITNESSES POINT JUST
NOW I THINK WHAT ADMINISTRATIVE
TEAMS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
IN NEED OF PARTICULARLY IN WHAT
IS THIS UNFORTUNATE NEW NORMAL.
IS CLARITY AND I DO THINK THAT
THE POINTS IN OPPOSITION RAISED
BY THE ACLU PARTICULARLY HER
MULTI POINT -- THINKING ON ON
WHAT SHOULD BE ADDED TO PROVIDE
THAT CLARITY WOULD BE WORTH
CONSIDERING IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE WERE CONSIDERING
TAKING UP YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND I
THINK THAT WE HAVE A QUITE A BIT
OF COMMON GROUND HERE I MEAN
THAT.
THE POINT IS CERTAINLY NOT -- TO
GET MORE KIDS INTO THE A LITTLE
JUSTICE SYSTEM I THINK TO THE
CONTRARY -- ONE OF THE
ADVANTAGES OF HAVING -- A SET OF
BEST PRACTICES IN A PROTOCOL IS
NOT ONLY THE YOU MAKE SURE YOU
DON'T MISS TRUE WARNING SIGNS
BUT ALSO THAT YOU DOWNTOWN I
OVER REACT TO THINGS THAT ARE --
HARMLESS AND TRANSIENT AND SO I
THINK THAT THE BILL SERVES THAT
PURPOSE AND THAT MISTER
MCCARTY'S POINTS ARE WELL TAKEN
I MEAN THIS IS IT NEEDS TO BE
COUPLED.
WITH A RENEWED FOCUS ON MENTAL
HEALTH -- AND THE PROFESSIONALS
WHO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN OUR SCHOOLS YOU KNOW
WE HAD A INFORMATIONAL HEARING
THIS COMMITTEE A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO ON THAT TOPIC AND STEMMING
FROM THAT AT CHAIR O'DONNELL AND
HIGHER.
GENTLY OFFERING TWO BILLS THAT --
SEEK.
TO IMPROVE SERVICES IN THAT AREA
SO -- I THINK THAT -- THE OINTS
ABOUT TAKEN AND LOOKING FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION.
RIGHT WILL GIVEN YOUR COMMITMENT
AND TO CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
ACTS I THINK THAT LEVEL OF
CLARITY IS REALLY IMPORTANT I
WILL SECOND THE MEASURE.
IN -- SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M SORRY YOU WANTED TO LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA MCCARTY.
A SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL.
WELL I WEBER.
THE BILL HAS THREE ABOUT SO IT'S
ON CALL THANK YOU MISTER KILEY.
I'M NEXT WILL HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING.
FILE ITEM -- TWELVE BILL NUMBER.
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE RIGHT NOW IT'S
AYE.
OKAY WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TENGAN YOU MAY START YOUR
PRESENTATION AS READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- FOR
SUCH DESPITE THE THE CHAIR IN
UPSTATE TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THAT WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS ARE PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE -- ARE BARRED BILL IS --
AROUND EARLY EDUCATION I THE
DISTINCT HONOR TO BE ON THE
SPEAKERS BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
WHICH MISTER MCCARTY COCHAIRED
IT ONE OF THOSE ITEMS THAT COP
BROUGHT UP IS REALLY THE OF
STRUCTURE.
OF HOW THE MEMBERSHIP OF THESE
LOCAL PLANNING COUNCILS IS MADE --
BY THE COUNTIES IS A WE'RE GONNA
WANT TO DO IS PROPOSE THAT WE
MAKE A FEW CHANGES TO THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THESE LOCAL
PLANNING COUNCILS WHICH REALLY.
HELPED -- MANAGE AND PROVIDE
ADVICE.
TO DIFFERENT EARLY CHILD
EDUCATION CENTERS -- IN THE
VARIOUS COUNTIES AROUND THE
STATE.
I WANT TO CHANGE THE MEMBERSHIP
OF THE LOCAL THE LOCAL PLANNING
COUNCILS AND TO CALL NEW
STRATEGIC PLANNING COUNCILS
WHICH OF REPRESENTS
REPRESENTATIVES.
ACROSS THE EARLY EDUCATION AND
CHILDCARE SPECTRUM.
IT ALSO SETS CLEAR EXPECTATIONS
RELATED TO DATA COLLECTION
STANDARDS.
THE RESPONSIBILITIES FOR BOTH
THE COUNCILS IN THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION IT ALSO GIVES THE
COUNTIES MORE FLEXIBILITY IN THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE COUNCIL TO
HELP MAKE THE MODEL FIT BOTH BIG
AND SMALL COUNTY STYLES I WAS
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
HAVE.
SENT.
OUT WITH THAT I BELIEVE WE HAVE --
TWO WITNESSES HERE TO SPEAK VERY
BRIEFLY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL FOR A. B.. ONE THOUSAND
ONE THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF
MY NAME'S MICHAEL GARCIA WITH
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THE LOCAL CHILD CARE
PLANNING COUNCIL FOR SENATOR
COUNTY.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON AB ONE
ZERO ZERO ONE LOCAL CHILDCARE
PLANNING COUNCILS ARE -- PC'S
CURRENTLY SERVE AN IMPORTANT
FUNCTION OF BRING TOGETHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN IDENTIFYING NEED
FOR CHILDCARE AND GAPS IN
SERVICES.
ALTHOUGH PC'S PROVIDE AN
IMPORTANT FOR FOR STAKEHOLDERS
BUT NOT ALL OF HIS HE'S INCLUDE
ALL THE ENTITIES THAT ARE NEEDED
AT THE TABLE TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS.
FIRST FIVE ALTERNATE PAYMENT
PROVIDER STYLE FIVE STATE
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
HIGHER EDUCATION RESOURCE --
FROM NETWORKS HAS STAR PROVIDERS
HEALTH AND WELFARE AGENCIES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY-OFFICE OF EDUCATION ARE ALL
VITAL PARTNERS IN PLANNING AND
INVESTING IN EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION -- ECP.
AS AN LPC COORDINATOR IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY FOR THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS I'VE HAD THE GOOD
FORTUNE TO BUILDING FOSTER
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THESE VITAL
PARTNERS TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL
EASY NEEDS.
ARE IDENTIFIED AND ADDRESSED AB
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE WOULD HELP ALL
OF BC'S BUILDING MAINTAIN
EFFECTIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS.
BECAUSE OF THE STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WE HAVE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND SUPPORT WE
RECEIVED TO THE COUNTY OFFICE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY HAS BEEN ABLE
TO GO ABOVE AND BEYOND OUR
MANDATE A CHILD CARE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT.
BY CREATING A CHILD CARE
FACILITY STUDY TO PROVIDE DATA
AND INSIGHT INTO THE EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION FACILITY NEEDS FOR
OUR COUNTY.
THE STUDY INCLUDES CRITICAL
INFORMATION FROM ELECTED FOR
ELECTED OFFICIALS CITY IN
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSIONS HOUSING DEVELOPERS
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
AND ALL OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
INTERESTED INTEGRATING EASY
EXPANSION.
INTO SUSTAINABLE SYSTEMS OF
FUNDING WILL BE PRESENTING THIS
INFORMATION TO CITY COUNTY
PLANNING BODIES TO HELP INFORM
AND ENCOURAGE THEM TO INVEST IN
NEW EASY FACILITIES.
IN CLOSING AB ONE ZERO ZERO ONE
STRENGTHENS AL FRANKEN'S ALL
PC'S ENCOURAGES ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AT THE TABLE AND LINKS ALL --
PC'S TEEN INVESTMENTS IN EASY
INCLUDING QUALITY COUNTS
CALIFORNIA TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND ADDRESSES GAPS
IN PLANNING FOR EASY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
THE MEDICARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION --
WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THAT HAS A BROAD COALITION
OF SUPPORT FROM EARLY EDUCATION
CHILD CARE DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES WELL FOR AGENCIES AND
LABOR.
AND I'LL SEED ANY ADDITIONAL
TIME FOR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
UNDER MALIK DILLMAN I WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE
COORDINATORS ASSOCIATION.
AND THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
CHILDCARE PARTNERSHIP COUNCIL
AND COUNTY OFFICE OF ED.
IN SUPPORT.
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
THROUGH THE JUNK FOR CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY OF LOCAL PLANNING
COUNCIL SUPPORT.
KIM JONG ON THE OTHER SAN BENITO
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
IN SUPPORT.
NICK ROAMING THE HALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT.
LARA DURING THE CEO OF THE
NONPROFIT GO KIDS ALSO THE CO
CHAIR OF THE CHUCK COMPLAIN
COUNSEL FOR SANTA CRUZ IN PASCO
CHAIR FOR MODERATE US.
A SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND WE HOLD
THE CONTRACT FOR LP SEES IN SAN
BENITO COUNTY.
IN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON BEVERLY YOU ON
BEHALF OF U. D. W. ASKED ME
LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT.
AARON GABLE ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MICHELLE STILL APARTMENTS HE
WITH CANANGA INSTEAD IN SUPPORT.
INJURIES FISHER WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY TOWN PRESENTED
WE HAVE THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY SPEAKERS OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NONE WILL RETURN IT
TO THE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SOME OF I'LL SECOND MISTER TING
WOULD LIKE CLOSE JUST RESPECT
FOR US FOR HALF OF THANK YOU.
CLICK TO CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA MCCARTY.
AYE MCCARTY AYE AYES SMITH SMITH
I VOEPEL [inaudible]
WEBER.
MUCH HAS THREE ROADS PHONE CALL
THANK YOU.
ITEM NUMBER NINE OUR NEXT WILL
CALL MISS WICKS WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB.
EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE THIS WEEK'S
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR [inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
I I THINK IS AS MOST OF US KNOW
AN EXPERIENCE AND SEE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE ISSUES FACED
IT ROUND POVERTY IN THE STATE --
AND WHEN YOU SPECIAL YOU LOOK AT
THE ERODING SOCIAL SAFETY NET.
AT THE FEDERALLEVEL IT'S AN
ISSUE I KNOW MANY OF US ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT FRANKLY.
PROBABLY REASON MY MANY OF US
FROM THESE JOBS IS BECAUSE WE
CARE ABOUT THIS AND WANT TO
CREATE.
A STRONG SOCIAL SAFETY NET I WE
WANT ENSURE OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO HOUSING AND FOOD AND
THE HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED -- WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
LITERALLY MILLIONS OF CHILDREN
LIVING IN POVERTY?
MILLIONS OF CHILDREN LIVING IN
POVERTY IN THE STATE.
AND IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS AROUND THOSE CHILDREN
LIVING IN POVERTY IT'S
DISPROPORTIONATELY KIDS OF COLOR.
NO THERE'S A RACIAL INEQUITY
ISSUE HERE THAT I KNOW MANY OF
YOU HAVE WORKED ON THESE ISSUES
BUT I KNOW DR A LOT OF OUR WORK
IN A LOT OF OUR THINKING -- A
LOT OF THESE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES LIKE THAT LACK THE
ACCESS -- AND RESOURCES TO
EDUCATIONAL.
RESOURCES TO HEALTH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SUCH TRIBE WE
HAD A REALLY GOOD PROGRAM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA CALLED HEALTHY
START.
AND IT EXISTED FROM NINETEEN
NINETY TWO TO TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN IT WAS ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION -- ADDED IN SHORT THAT
DOES THERE WAS FUNDING FOR TO
ENSURE THAT KIDS HAD ACCESS TO
THESE RESOURCES TO ACCESS IS. TO
TO TO MEDI CAL TO CAL FOR US TO
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES.
THAT PROGRAM ENDED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND WHAT MY BILL
IS DESIGNED TO DO IS -- TO START
TO HEALTHY START INITIATIVE
AGAIN HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ENSURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO CREATE THAT
SOCIAL SAFETY NET TO ENSURE THAT
OUR KIDS THAT MOST NEEDED THE
MOST DESPERATELY NEED.
TO GET THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED A WE KNOW WHEN THEY GET
THESE RESOURCES WE SEE AN
INCREASE AND IMMUNIZATIONS WE
SEE IT -- BETTER SCORES IN
READING AND AND MATH WE SEE A
DECREASE IN DRUG USAGE.
THIS IS THE THINGS THESE ARE THE
THINGS WE SHOULD BE DOING -- IN
OUR COMMUNITIES -- THAT IS WHAT
MY BILL IS AIMED TO DO -- IS IS
TO RESTART THE HEALTHY START
INITIATIVE -- I WANT TO THANK MY
SPONSORS ON THIS BILL UNITED WAY
OF CALIFORNIA THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND AS WELL.
I CALIFORNIA'S FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE -- THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
I KNOW IMPACTS MANY
ORGANIZATIONS AND MANY FOLKS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES -- I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND I WANT TO
TURN IT OVER -- TO MIGHT
WITNESSES TODAY AND HAVE THEM
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR IN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LINDSAY CALLAHAN I AM
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF UNITED
WAY FRESNO MADERA COUNTIES.
I'M HONORED TO BE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY ON SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SEVENTY FIVE ON HEALTHY START
TWO POINT NO WHICH IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL.
AND THANKS TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE WE
ALL WANT OUR CHILDREN TO BE
HAPPY WE ALL WONDER CHILDREN TO
BE HEALTHY WE ALL WANT OUR
CHILDREN TO THRIVE.
BUT CALIFORNIA FRANKLY HAS
UNEVEN TRACK RECORD.
WHEN IT COMES TO MAKING GOOD ON
OUR SHARED GOALS OF HEALTHY
BEGINNINGS A NURTURING
ENVIRONMENTS?
INSTEAD WE'VE CREATED A SILO
SYSTEM THAT REACTS ONLY WHEN
CHILDREN ARE CLEARLY STRUGGLING
IN IN CRISIS AND EVEN THEN TOO
OFTEN WE'RE NOT SITUATED TO
ACTUALLY RESPOND AND WE FAIL THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
WE KNOW THAT OUR CHILDREN WHO
ARE ENGLISH LEARNERS.
FOSTER YOUTH AND COME FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES FACE THESE
ISSUES EVEN MORE
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
IT'S A STARK REALITY THAT AYE
PAIN I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT IT'S ONE THAT I'VE SEEN IN
MY COMMUNITY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND ONE I'VE SEEN
STATEWIDE IN THE WORK THAT I'VE
DONE OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
TODAY I'M HERE TO SAY THAT WE
CAN DO BETTER.
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN JUST
TRYING TO DIMINISH HARMER LESSEN
INEQUITIES WE HAVE BUILT WE CAN
CREATE GOOD IN AB EIGHT SEVENTY
FIVE DOES JUST THAT.
IN MY COMMUNITY WE OFTEN SAY
TOGETHER WE ARE BETTER.
HEALTHY START AS ENVISIONED BY
THIS BILL HAS THE SAME PREMISE
IT'S OUR DUTIES DUTY AS PUBLIC
SERVANTS. TO ACT COLLECTIVELY TO
PROVIDE CHILDREN FAMILIES WITH
ALL THE TOOL SUPPORTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY NEED TO
LIVE FULL LIVES AND THE SIMPLE
FACT THAT IS THAT THE SCHOOL.
IS A WHERE GREAT DEAL THE
CHILDHOOD HAPPENS AND IT JUST
MAKES SENSE TO USE THIS AS A
NATURAL HUB TO INTEGRATE
SERVICES FOR MENTAL HEALTH FOOD
ACCESS ECONOMIC CHIEF OF SUPPORT
AND REALLY SO MUCH MORE THE LIST
GOES ON AND ON THIS IS HOW WE
CAN ADDRESS THE VERY.
REAL ISSUES THAT ARE MANY THAT
ARE FAMILIES AND CHILDREN ARE
FACING.
HEALTHY START TO POINT --
CONFRONTS THE CHALLENGES WITH AN
ARRAY OF COMMUNITY RESPONSE OF
STRATEGIES THAT ARE PROACTIVE IN
LEVERAGING THE MANY LOCAL
FUNDING SOURCES ALREADY IN
EXISTENCE.
I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND HOW
WRAPPING CHILDREN FAMILIES IN
THE COORDINATED SUPPORT THEY
NEED AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE
DRAMATICALLY ALTERS THE COURSE
OF THEIR LIVES FOR THE BETTER.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AIDS AB
EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
HI -- THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME MY
NAME IS ALYA ROMMEL'S I WORK AT
THE RICE YOU CENTER -- IN
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE
TO DO IS.
BE PROOF THAT I AM THIS ACTUALLY
WORKS THE HEALTHY START REALLY
SUPPORTED RICE -- AND I WAS A
YOUTH.
THAT WAS CONSIDERED LIKE THE
WORST USE LIKE MY IN OR LIKE YOU
KNOW I HAD THE CHANCE THE WORST
CHALLENGES I FELT -- MY PARENTS
RUN DOCUMENTING IT MY FAMILY WAS
AT THE MISTAKE VIOLENCE
HOUSEHOLD -- I WAS LIKE THE
BLACK SHEEP ALWAYS IN TROUBLE
NEVER GOOD IN SCHOOL -- AND
GOING TO RISE REALLY SUPPORTING
ME IN MY JOURNEY IN LIFE -- I
NEVER THOUGHT I COULD BE BETTER
YOU KNOW EVERYONE ALWAYS TOLD ME
ALL YOU CAN BE DRUG AT A YEAR TO
GET PREGNANT AT FIFTEEN ANY DAY
I MEAN A GAME.
ALL THESE NEGATIVE THINGS BUT
WHEN I WENT TO RISE A GAVE ME
LIKE A SAFE HAVEN LIKE I JUST
STARTED GOING THEY ACTUALLY
CARED ABOUT ME I FELT LIKE IT
WAS MY HOME I DON'T.
LIKE BEING HOME SO I WOULD RUN
AWAY THERE -- AND THEY HELP ME
WITH SCHOOL I ACTUALLY STARTED
DOING -- GOING TO COUNSELING --
AND SORRY -- OTHER GOING ACCOUNT
SAYING AND I STARTED GETTING
HELP WITH SCHOOL AND I GOT I
GRADUATED WHICH I THINK I WOULD
DO -- I GOT INTO LIKE FOUR C. IS
USE LIKE ALSO THEY DIDN'T THINK
I WOULD DO IS JUST THEM GIVING
ME ALL THESE OPPORTUNITIES ALL
THESE SERVICES TO TELL ME LIKE
YOU CAN DO IT YOU JUST HAVE TO
BELIEVE A LIKE TRY YOU COULD DO
IT HERE'S EVERYTHING YOU NEED.
FOR FREE SO YOU CAN DO IT AND
LIKE FOR ME MY APPEARS LIKE WE
ALL WENT THROUGH THIS INTERNSHIP
AND WE MANAGED TO DO IT NOW I
WORK THERE SO I'MABLE TO
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT REALLY DOES WORK AND I DON'T
HAVE A LIMITED TIME REALLY FIGHT
BUT PLEASED TO SUPPORT AS IT'S
IT'S REAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL IT IS.
NO YES YEAH WELL JUST AS QUICK
SUPPORT AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS FANTASTIC THANK YOU ON
SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT PLEASE.
JANICE COUNSELORS DEFENSE FUND
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S TRUST
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DEANNA NEIGHBOR WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HELEN ROSS THOUSAND TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY KIDS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THE DEARBORN REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT.
ANDRE PERRY WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUST AS A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND WE ARE
EXTREMELY THANKFUL FOR THE OFF
THEIR BRING THIS BOARD THANK YOU.
HI JAN DIETRICH ON BEHALF OF THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN SUPPORT.
YOU HAVE NO ERROR OCCURS ON
BEHALF OF THE MARCH OF DIMES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE WILL
RETURN IT TO MEMBERS MEMBERS
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
YES THANK YOU ALL FIRST OF ALL
ON MOVE THIS MEASURE.
A SECOND OKAY.
AND YEAH -- YEAH I'M I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THESE THESE
PROGRAMS I JUST WANNA KNOW TO
THIS WAS ODD EMBRACED AND HELP
CREATED BY GOVERNOR PETE WILSON.
SOMETIMES WE ALWAYS MENTION HIS
NAME WITH GOOD THOUGHTS BUT THIS
WAS A BIPARTISAN ISSUE -- AND WE
HAVE THIS GOING ON FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS -- AND OF COURSE DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION WE WALKED A
LOT OF STUFF IN THIS THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE ONE OF THOSE PROGRAMS
AND SO.
YOU KNOW REALLY THIS IS AN ISSUE%
FOR OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE WHICH
I'M I'M PART OF AND WORKING WITH
YOU TO MAKE SURE FRANKLY WE
PROBABLY FUND OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE OTHER
FLIPSIDE IS IS THAT NOT ONLY DO
WE WHACK A LOS STUFF DURING THE
RECESSION WHEN WE RECOVERED.
WE REFUNDED -- PROGRAMS THROUGH
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUT SAID WE
WANTED TO SQUEEZE THESE
CATEGORICAL AS AN LED DISTRICTS
ASIDE SO CONCEIVABLY.
IN EL SAX CITY DISTRICT COULD
CREATE THESE HEALTHY START
PROGRAMS IN OAKLAND BUT AS WE
KNOW.
THERE'S STRUGGLING JUST KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON AND SO I'M I'M ALL IN
ON THIS SITE I REMEMBER VISITING
MY FIRST FIRST FIVE SITE IN --
MIGHT THE FORMER CITY COUNCIL
DISTRICT.
AND I SAW THE WORK THAT THEY DID
THEIR WITH FAMILIES AND KIDS
AFTER SCHOOL AND THEY MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN THEIR BIG PART OF
THE COMMUNITY CELL AYE I AM ALL
IN ON THESE HEALTHY START --
INITIATIVES IN SUPPORT THIS TO
POINT OUT -- BUT BUT AGAIN I
JUST YOU KNOW THE REALITY CHECK
IS THAT WE NEED TO WORK ON
ADEQUATE FUNDING OF OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN.
RE GREEN LIGHT EFFORTS LIKE THIS
YEP THANKS AGREE.
I ECHO MISTER MCCARTY'S AND YOU
KNOW SUPPORT THE MEASURE FOR ALL
THE RIGHT REASONS YOU KNOW IT
EARLIER AND IN IN COMMITTEE
TODAY WE PASSED A MEASURE FOR
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS RIGHT BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT IT'S THESE HOLISTIC.
PROGRAMMING MEASURES THAT WORK
WHEN WE'RE SUPPORTING THE WHOLE
CHILD THEIR NUTRITIONAL NEEDS
THEIR SOCIO ECONOMIC NEEDS TO
THE EXTENT WE CAN IN THEIR
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING -- THEY
HAVE GREATER ACADEMIC SUCCESS
AND THAT IS JUST WHERE WE ARE IN
TERMS OF REALLY NEEDING TO
INCLUDE THOSE ELEMENTS TO
ENTIRELY CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP SO -- WITHOUT I'M STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE I WILL
REMIND OUR COLLEAGUES AT THIS
ENJOYS A DO PASS MOTION AND SO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE.
JUST I THINK A THE STORY SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CLICK OR CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL KILEY.
KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH SMITH I
VOEPEL WEBER.
WHAT IS THE UP TO BOTH THE BILLS
ON CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT MISTER MCCARTY.
FILE ITEM ONE MEASURE
.
ONE TWO THREE JUST YOU AND I
HERE.
WELL THANK YOU -- MADAM VICE
VICE CHAIR.
FIRST OF ALL LIKE.
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS MEASURE THIS OF
COURSE IS AB. ONE TWO THREE IT'S
THAT PRE K. FOR ALL BILL AND WE
THINK IT SHOULD BE EASY AS ONE
TWO THREE SIMPLE AS THAT YOU
KNOW.
IT'S TIME THAT CALIFORNIA STEPS
UP AND FOR FEELS THE PROMISE OF
PRESCHOOL FOR ALL.
NO WE HAD STATES ACROSS THE
NATION THAT ARE THAT ARE DOING
THIS RED STATES.
AND AND BLUE STATES IN
CALIFORNIA LEADS IN SO MANY
ISSUES BUT THIS ONE WERE
UNFORTUNATELY BEHIND AND THERE
ARE.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
KIDS WHO START KINDERGARTEN
EVERY YEAR.
WHO HAD HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GO TO A QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
EXIST AND THAT'S THAT'S THE WHY
WHY THIS MATTERS BECAUSE?
WE WANT TO ADDRESS THE STUBBORN
AND LINGERING EDUCATION
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
WE WANT TO ADDRESS -- POVERTY
SPECIFICALLY INTERGENERATIONAL
POVERTY.
AND OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE WAS THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
THE NUMBER ONE PLACE THAT YOU
COULD INVEST THAT RESEARCH SHOWS
IS EARLY EDUCATION AND THAT'S
WHAT THAT THIS MEASURE IS ALL
ABOUT.
SO THIS WOULD GO WOULD CREATE --
A AN EFFORT HERE IT'S NOT A NEW
PROGRAM WE WOULD BUILD UPON OUR
EXISTING CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY. TO NEARLY SEVENTY
THOUSAND THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS IN CALIFORNIA WE FOCUS ON
INCREASING QUALIFICATIONS FOR
THE WORK FORCE.
AND PROVIDE THEM A RESOURCE AND
SCHOLARSHIPS TO FOCUS ON GETTING
THIS THESE NEW EDUCATION -- THAT
IS THE EDUCATION UP PIECES TO IT
TO HELP IN THEIR CLASSROOMS IN
THEIR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
AND WE WOULD ALSO FOCUS ON
INCREASING PAY FOR THE WORK
FORCE BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT.
A STABLE WORKFORCE MEANS QUALITY
AND CERTAINLY HELPS THE THE THE
EXISTING WORKFORCE AS WELL.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT -- WE
CAN'T DO THIS OVERNIGHT SO THIS
EFFORT IS THAT WE CALL TARGETED
UNIVERSALISM IT'S A FIRST OUT
STEP OF A OF A HOPEFULLY.
THEY AT A THREE TO FIVE YEAR
PERIOD TO FOCUS ON PRESCHOOL FOR
ALL IN CALIFORNIA FOCUSINGON
THE KIDS WHO NEEDED THE MOST.
AND WE HAVE VISITED STATES
THROUGHOUT THE NATION TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THEY HAVE DONE IT AND WE
BROUGHT BACK THIS EFFORT HERE.
ALSO PROUD TO KNOW THAT ARE
ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
WHICH HAS BEEN NOTED TODAY A BLU
RAY COMMISSION EARLY EDUCATION
FOCUS ON THESE EXACT ELEMENTS
ARE LOOKING AT BEST PRACTICES
WHAT COULD BE DONE.
CERTAINLY THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR LOOKING
AT OUR BUDGET PROCESS BUT THIS
IS A COMPANION LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL.
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET --
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR
SO WITH ME TODAY ARE BY THE
STEELERS ON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FROM EARLY ADS CALIFORNIA.
AND DR BETTY ROBINSON HARRISON
EARLY EDUCATOR FROM THE PAST
STAFF UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA.
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR PENNY ROBINSON
HARRIS I AM IN THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
I'M CELEBRATING FORTY SEVEN
YEARS AND WORKING WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN.
I STILL SMILE EVERY MORNING WHEN
I WITH MY CHILDREN AND I CREATE
THEM AND TELL THEM GOODBYE.
DALY HOPEFUL AND INSPIRED BY THE
WAY THAT THEY LITTLE BODIES.
I'M STILL.
PASSIONATELY IN LOVE WITH MY JOB.
I AM THE CHAIR OF THE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE FOR SAFETY
WHO IS A CO SPONSOR.
BUT I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING --
MANY OR THE CHILD EDUCATION
TEACHERS AND EDUCATORS TO
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THE VALUE OF
EARLY TO OUT EDUCATION I LIVE IT
EVERY DAY.
IN THE FAMILIES INTO WE OFTEN
FEARFUL CHILDREN IN TWO YEARS.
OF THE LITTLE ONES -- FEARFUL
BUT GRADUATING LEAVING THE
SCHOOLS STRONG FEARLESS A THIRD
OF AN READY TO TAKE ON THE WORLD.
I WITNESS THE MAGIC OF
RELATIONSHIPS WHEN WE SEE
PARENTS GUARDIANS AND CARETAKERS
DAILY.
AN EXAMPLE WOULD BE ON HILL WHO
CAME INTO MY CLASSROOM THREE
YEARS AGO -- THREE YEARS OLD NO
ENGLISH.
HIS MOMMY STILL IN MEXICO.
HIS BROTHER SAID TO HIM LESS
THAN -- NINE MONTHS LATER WHAT
DO YOU SPEAK ENGLISH.
BETTER THAN ME.
I ALSO REFERENCE OF FAMILY THAT
I I WORKED WITH DEAL CAME IN
WITH GRANDMOTHER.
DAVE CAME IN WITH A MOTHER.
SEAN CAME IN WITH GRANDMOTHER
[inaudible]
BUT JUNE CAME IN WITH MOM.
AND MOM HEAD REHABILITATIVE
HERSELF.
HAD WITH THE SCHOOL.
HAD TRAINED TO BECOME A BUS
DRIVER.
AND JOHN THE FIRST CHAU.
GRADUATED IN WITH THE WEST POINT.
THESE ARE JUST EXAMPLES OF WHAT
EARLY EDUCATION DOES NOT ONLY
FOR CHILDREN.
IT WORKS FOR FAMILIES
COMMUNITIES AND FOR THE GREATER
GOOD OF OUR SOCIETY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS BUT
THE SALAS SUNAL I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EARLY AT
TO CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB.
ONE TWO THREE AB ONE TWO THREE
PROVIDES.
CRITICAL SUPPORTS TO
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES BY EXPANDING ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY STATE BRICKS
PRESCHOOL TO OVER.
SEVENTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
CHILDREN.
AB ONE TWO THREE ALSO INCREASES
BAY AND QUALIFICATIONS OF
PRESCHOOL TEACHER.
I BEGAN MY CAREER AS A PRESCHOOL
TEACHER.
SO I KNOW WHEN I SAW FIRST HAND
THE VALUE OF BEING IN THE
CLASSROOM -- I STILL REMEMBER MY
FIRST DAY -- IN THE CLASSROOM IN
A CLASSROOM FULL OF TWO YEAR
OLDS AND I THOUGHT.
OH THIS IS EASY NO -- YOU KNOW
THE TEACHERS REQUIRE A LOT OF
SUPPORT AND RECOGNITIONS THAT IS
NOT RIGHT NOTE THAT WE NEED TO
WORK ON SO I THINK.
YOU KNOW THE GOOD THING ABOUT AB
ONE TWO THREE IS THAT -- IN
ADDITION TO EXPANDING AXIS WHICH
IS REALLY NEEDED IT'S ALSO
THINKING ABOUT QUALITY.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT -- INVESTING
IN OUR TEACHERS IT'S ONE OF THE
KEY ELEMENTS AT TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY IN THE CLASSROOMS SO --
YOU KNOW ITS -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY MENTION WE DID A TOUR --
TO THE EAST COAST AND SERVE --
SOME REALLY HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAMS AND THE COMMON ELEMENT
BETWEEN THESE CITIES WAS THAT
THE SUPPORT TO THE TEACHERS SO
ALL TEACHERS HOW TO BE A PLUS
AND CREDENTIAL.
THEY WERE ALL PAID AT PARITY
WITH KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS AND
THEY ALSO I RECEIVED COACHING SO
I THINK YOU KNOW THAT WITH THE
KEY TAKE AWAY -- YOU KNOW THE
ALL THESE ELEMENTS HAVE THE TO
BE PRESENT AND I THINK THAT AB
ONE TWO THREE IS -- IS
SUPPORTING THAT PIECE -- SO AS
WE ALL SAID YOU KNOW WE KNOW THE
RESEARCH ARE LEARNING WORKS SO --
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO TO
STEP UP AND YOU KNOW SUPPORT OUR
TEACHERS AND PROVIDE ACCESS TO
ALL THE KIDS THAT NEED IT -- SO
AT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO ALL
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PREVENTS YOU WITH TODAY GO PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR.
RUN RAMPANT BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF AB ONE TWO THREE
THANK YOU.
OLDER SHILOH WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
THE CHALLENGE OF IT TO THE
BATHROOM PROJECT CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
JEFF PARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible] EIGHT YOUR MAILLET
DILLMAN A CALIFORNIA TELL CARE
COORDINATORS ASSOCIATION.
AND THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
CHILDCARE PARTNERSHIP COUNCIL
[inaudible]
PLEASE SUPPORT.
PATTY HERRERA REPRESENTING
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
ZAKHO COMMITTEES FATHER OF TWO
PRE K. AGE CHILDREN AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL GARCIA SENECA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TO GET WHICH
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BECAUSE SOMEONE WAS ARAMBULA --
PRESCHOOL TEACHER APPLICABLE IN
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT AND I
HAVE BEEN TEACHING PRESCHOOL FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS THANK YOU.
MARK THE ARBORS AND WE HAVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT.
AB BEER AMERICA'S ON THE HAVE A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
SING NO MORE SUPPORT ANY UP.
BY OPPOSITION -- PETRA MORE TEAR
WITH FIGHT CRIME INVEST IN KIDS
IN SUPPORT.
A A SINGLE MORE SO ANY
OPPOSITION.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVE AS THE
NUMBER THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING.
I WE WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARTY FOR HIS COMMITMENT
TO EDUCATING ALL EARLY LEARNERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR ORGANIZATION WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT IN ORDER TO
DO SO WE NEED THE FOLLOWING
AMENDMENTS -- THE BILL GIVES A
NOD TO THE MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM
BUT IT FAILED TO SPECIFY HOW IT
WILL INCLUDE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE CARE
480% OF CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED DIRECT CONTRACTS CBO'S
TO BE SPELLED OUT IN THE BILL.
WE NEED THE THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS IN THE LOW INCOME AREAS TO
BE SERVED BY CBO'S.
WE NEED INCOME TO BE VERIFIED
USING ON VERIFIED INCOME
INCREASES RATES FOR HONEST
MIDDLE AND LOWER AND MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES SQUEEZE AN AMOUNT
OF CARE AND EXACERBATING THE
EARLY LEARNING CARE ISSUE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
HI I'M CARRIE ROBERTS FROM
YELLOW COUNTY OFF OF IT SICK
CHILD CARE I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BA. FOR
TEACHERS WHO ARE ALREADY IN THIS
FIELD -- THEY WORK FULL TIME
MOST OF THEM ARE SINGLE MOMS TO
BE VERY PROBLEMATIC FOR THEM TO
GO TO SCHOOL AND WORK -- AND PAY
THEIR BILLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A SINGLE MORE
OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENTS READY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MISS SMITH.
I JUST LIKE TO THANK THE THE
AUTHOR ALL THOSE WHO SERVED ON
THAT YOU KNOW THE TASK FORCE I
AM I AM LATE TO THIS
CONVERSATION JUST BASED ON WHEN
I GOT ELECTED TO BE HERE BUT
I'VE BEEN INCREDIBLY IMPRESSED
WITH HOW DILIGENT.
YOU AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN IN
REALLY VETTING BEST PRACTICES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY I MEAN FROM
TOURS AND VISITS TO VERY
THOROUGH RESEARCH I ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT PERSPECTIVE
YOU'VE TAKEN FROM THE POT PUBLIC
POLICY APPROACH WHICH IS.
NOT TO TRY TO ENTIRELY REINVENT
THE WHEEL HERE BUT TO LOOK AT
EXISTING STRUCTURES IN
CALIFORNIA AND HOW WE CONTINUE
TO EMPOWER AND BUILD ON THOSE TO
GET TO THE SYSTEM WE EVENTUALLY
WOULD ALL LIKE TO SEE WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW -- PRESCHOOL EDUCATION
FOR ALSO I'M EXCITED TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE AND I MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED --
I'LL SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU -- TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS YES
THE MOST UP.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU I I FIRST WANT TO
THANK ALL THE SUPPORTERS WE HAVE
A BROAD COALITION AND A LOT OF
LEGISLATIVE SUPPORTERS INCLUDING
SOME IN THE AUDIENCE OF APPEAR
SO.
SO THANK YOU THIS IS A BIG
COALITION TRY TO MAKE THIS THE
YEAR THAT WE FINALLY TO FILL THE
PRE K. FOR ALL PROMISED MY
STICKER BY THE WAY -- BUT I DO
WANT TO ACCEPT THAT ADDRESS THE
TWO OPPOSITION POINTS ONE
THERE'S A MAN IN THE BILL FOR
THE BA SO WE'RE ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE SO WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH
THAT.
INDIVIDUAL FROM YOLO COUNTY AND
THEN AS FAR AS THE THE THE OTHER.
ORGANIZATION I THINK A LOT OF
THOSE THOSE CONCERNS ARE ARE
PART OF THE PROPOSAL WILL
CERTAINLY SPEND MORE TIME
BECAUSE WE DO -- ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS IS A MIXED DELIVERY
PROGRAM HERE AND WE'RE BUILDING
UPON THAT AND WE CAN'T REINVENT
THE WHEEL THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT'S THROUGH THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM MONDAY THROUGH
PROP.
NINETY EIGHT AND IS PART OF THE
EXISTING FABRIC AND WE WANT.
TO BUILD UPON AND WE THINK WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO
THIS YEAR.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US AND WITH THAT ASK THE
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE SMITH
SMITH I VOEPEL.
WEBER.
BUS THREE VOTES IT IS ON CALL
WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE TO MISTER
CHIU -- FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
SEVEN AB.
SEVEN ELEVEN AB SEVEN ALONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE MOMENTS AND THANK THE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY STUFF
ON THIS BILL.
TRANSGENDER NON BINARY STUDENTS
FACE MANY BARRIERS IN SCHOOL IN
THE WORKPLACE OUR STATE IS
TAKING MANY STEPS TO MAKE SURE
THAT TRANSGENDER STUDENTS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY IN SCHOOL
PROTECTED AND ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY IN SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES.
BUT THE LAWS BEEN SILENT ON THE
RIGHTS OF FORMER STUDENTS WHO
MAY HAVE TRANSITION OR OTHERWISE
COME OUT AFTER LEAVING SCHOOL.
THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL WOULD
ENSURE THAT TRANSGENDER AND NON
BINARY PEOPLE WHO ARE NO LONGER
IN SCHOOL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
UPDATE OLD DIPLOMAS AND
TRANSCRIPTS REFLECT.
THEIR CORRECT AND LEGAL NAME IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THIS THEY CAN
CURRENTLY FACE CHALLENGES
APPLYING FOR SCHOOL OR
EMPLOYMENT.
IF A PERSON'S TRANSCRIPT HAS THE
WRONG NAME A DOCUMENT CAN OUT
THAT PERSON AS TRANSGENDER TO
ANYONE WHO SEES IT WE'VE HEARD
STORIES OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
SUPERVISOR SAW INCORRECT NAMES
ON THEIR DVDS.
AND OUT OF THEM TO THEIR CO
WORKERS.
OUR STATE ALREADY REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO RECOGNIZE A
TRANSGENDER NON BINARY STUDENTS
NAME OR GENDER.
CHANGE COURT ORDER AND UP TO A
PERMANENT RECORDS THIS BILL
WOULD CLOSE THE GAP IN THE LAW
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS -- WOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE SAME RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS AFTER THEY GRADUATE
WITH THAT LIKE TO TURN OVER TO A
WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TAMMY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
THE STATE WIDE LGBT Q. CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION.
THEY WERE PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY
AS A CO SPONSOR OF AB SEVEN
ELEVEN WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
FORMER STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN ACADEMIC RECORDS LIKE
THEIR TRANSCRIPTS AND DIPLOMAS.
THAT ACCURATELY REFLECT THEIR
LEGAL NAME AND GENDER REGARDLESS
OF WHEN THEY GRADUATED.
AND WHEN THESE ACADEMIC RECORDS
DON'T REFLECT THE CORRECT
INFORMATION TRANSGENDER NON
BINARY STUDENTS AND TO USE THESE
DOCUMENTS TO APPLY FOR JOBS OR
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES ARE PUT AT
RISK OF DISCRIMINATION OR HARM.
AND THIS COMPOUNDS THE SOCIETAL
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING THAT LGBTQ PEOPLE
ALREADY FACE. EIGHTY SEVEN
ELEVEN IS A COMMON SENSE BILL
THAT WILL ADDRESS THIS INEQUITY.
AND SAFEGUARD THE PRIVACY OF ALL
GRADUATES INCLUDING A
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY
GRADUATES AND SURE THE
EDUCATIONAL RECORDS ARE ACCURATE
SO WE'RE GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU FOR HIS ATTENTION TO
THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
KAELIN JOHN ON THE OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. EIGHT
BILLION ONE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
I ANY OPPOSITION.
A SINGLE OPPOSITION WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE IT'S
BEEN MOVED ALL SECOND -- AND
JUST CLARIFY YOU ARE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU.
p[inaudible]
CLOSE [inaudible]
CLOSE.
OF I'M SORRY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
HAPPY NOT.
TO THE JOB THE MOTION IS DEEP
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL WEBER. TO
THE US TO VOTE SO IT IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
MISS CARILLO -- AB.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FIVE I THINK SHE'S NOT
HERE YES
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
GREAT [inaudible]
OKAY -- I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO BE
HERE TATE TODAY TO PRESENT AB.
TEN NINETY EIGHT I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- AS
IDENTIFIED IN THE ANALYSIS IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
VOTERS PASSED THE ADULT USE OF
MARIJUANA ACT.
A PORTION OF THE TAXES GENERATED
THROUGH THE LEGAL SALES OF
CANNABIS WILL BE DEPOSITED INTO
A YOUTH ACCOUNT. TO TO TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT OF SUBSTANCE
ABUSE THE ACCOUNT WILL FUND
EDUCATION PREVENTION.
EARLY INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT
OF YOUTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
THIS FUND IS TO BE ADMINISTERED
BY DH CS.
IN COLLABORATION WITH CD AND CD
PH.
YOU THE ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND DRUG
USE IS A SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERN YOU KNOW THIS.
TAXES GENERATED THROUGH THE
LEGAL SALE OF CANNABIS PROVIDE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
BY YOU BYE BYE YOUTH.
ESTIMATES BY THE LA -- SUGGESTS
THAT A THIRTIES THIRTY TO SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS COULD BE
AVAILABLE IN THE YOUTH ACCOUNT.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWO
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR WAS SILENT ON CERTAIN
CRITICAL FACTORS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CIRCUMVENT
THE PROCESS IDENTIFIED IN
PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR BUTRATHER IT SEEKS
TO PROVIDE SOME LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE FUNDS ARE
SPENT WISELY.
AND THE DESIRED OUTCOMES ARE
CLEARLY STATED.
IT CREATES A TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO ADVISE THE THREE
AGENCIES ON DATA COLLECTION
PROGRAM EVALUATION AND REPORTING.
IT ALSO REQUIRES MEASUREABLE
OUTCOMES IN REDUCING SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND IMPROVING EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE.
THE BILL SPECIFIES THAT PROGRAMS
FUNDED MUST BE EVIDENCE BASE.
FINALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
ACCOUNTABILITY OF ALL
EXPENDITURES AND OUT COMES
THROUGH REGULAR REPORTING.
THIS IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL.
TO ENSURE THAT FUNDS GENERATED
THROUGH THE TAXES ON THE LEGAL
SALE OF CANNABIS ARE USED IN AN
EFFECTIVE MANNER.
WE ARE PRO PROPOSING TO ADD AN
URGENCY BECAUSE TO ENSURE THAT
THE THREE AGENCIES BEGIN NOW TO
DO THE WORK NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THESE FUNDS ARE USED OF
AFFECTIVELY.
AS SOON AS SOON AS THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE. TO DATE.
ALTHOUGH THE FUNDS HAVE NOT YET
FLOWED INTO THE ACCOUNT THE
THREE DEPARTMENTS HAVE FAILED TO
UNDERTAKE THE PLANNING NECESSARY
TO ESTABLISH A PROGRAM.
END PROCESS IS NECESSARY TO
ALLOCATE THESE FUNDS -- THANK
YOU MANAGER.
THANK YOU THIRTY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
YES I GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
I'M JIM KEADY I'M WITH YOU
FORWARD.
WE AND WORKING WITH YOUTH
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE STATE
ON THE USE DOLLARS FROM.
PROP SIXTY FOUR THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF INTEREST IN
THIS WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WE APPRECIATED THE DIALOGUE
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND WE LIKE TO CONTINUE THAT
DIALOGUE PARTICULARLY RUN EQUITY
IN REDUCING DISPARITIES A
THROUGH THIS FINE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE NON FOR
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO SUPPORT THIS
BILL BUT ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS.
STEP AROUND THE CHILDREN OUR
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
REPORTER WITH A CRIME INVEST IN
KIDS SUMMER ALSO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
A SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NUMBER YOU'VE
ACTUALLY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MCCARTY THE QUESTION.
OKAY SECOND I WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR PLEASE CLOSE.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE OF THANK YOU
IMAGES SECOND THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL
WEBER [inaudible]
YEAH.
MR TERRIO THREE VOTE SO IT'S ON
CALL
.
IS NOT HERE.
SERVICE AGUIAR-CURRY GUESS AGO --
IT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible] FOR ELEVEN SORRY
ELEVEN THE WRITING EITHER TO ME
OR YOU.
BUT I I I I'M NOT GONNA CALL
PEOPLE THEY CAN'T WRITE.
YOU CAN DO THIS.
YOU CAN DO THIS -- EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY EIGHT I WOULDN'T ACCEPT A
MY CLASSROOM JUST SO YOU KNOW.
IT'S A LOT HIGHER EXPECTATIONS
OF YOU YOU SHOULD HAVE OF
YOURSELF A LOT OF THAT NAME.
YOU MAY RECEIVE ALREADY ON TAKE
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE
IN LINE WITH THE INTENT OF MY
BILL.
AB NINE FIFTY EIGHT CREATES THE
CALIFORNIA ORGANIC.
ORGANIC TO SCHOOL PILOT PROGRAM
WHICH WILL ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
APPLY FOR UP TO FIFTEEN CENTS OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING PER SCHOOL
MEAL TO PURCHASE ORGANIC
CALIFORNIA GROWN LOCALLY
PRODUCED FOODS.
SCHOOL MEALS PROVIDE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF FOOD AND NUTRITION FOR
MILLIONS OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND ARE A MAJOR SUPPORT
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
WELL COST AND AVAILABILITY
ISSUES PREVENT MANY COMMUTERS
FROM A SET ACCESSING LOCAL AND
IN SEASON FOODS.
MEALS PROVIDED IN THE SCHOOL
SETTING ARE A PRACTICAL WAY TO
INCREASE CHILDREN'S NUTRITION.
THIS BILL IS THE TRUE PILOT
WOULD WOULD WHAT I MEAN BY THAT
IS THAT.
IS TO DETERMINE ITS SUCCESS BOTH
THE PARTICIPATING SCHOOLS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE WILL REPORT BACK TO
US ON THE OUTCOMES.
THIS INFORMATION WILL ALLOW US
TO DECIDE WHETHER INVESTING IN
PROVIDING KIDS WITH HEALTHY
LOCAL FOOD IS MONEY WELL SPENT.
TOGETHER WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
WE HAVE MADE A BUDGET REQUEST TO
FUND THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROVIDING IT'S IT'LL THE
IMPORTANCE APPROVING ITS WORTH.
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES HERE TODAY
OR MAYBE.
THREE WHICH WHAT'S THE FIRST --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM DAVE RUNS AND I'M
THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS SAID DAVIS [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
PROMOTED ORGANIC FARMING SINCE
THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
SO WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL -- MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
SAID OUR ORGANIC FARMERS AND WE
FOUND THAT QUITE A NUMBER THEM
SELL ORGANIC PRODUCE -- TO LOCAL
SCHOOLS FOR EXAMPLE SEVERAL
ORGANIC FARMERS IN YOLO COUNTY
SELL PRODUCE TO THE WINNERS
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WHERE -- THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN WAS --
MAYOR.
OF COURSE IN THE LARGER URBAN
AREAS.
SUCH PRODUCE WILL COME FROM
LARGE FARMING OPERATIONS BUT
THERE ARE SEVERAL THOUSAND
ORGANIC FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA
NOW.
INCLUDING OVER ONE THIRD OF THE
MEMBERS OF WESTERN GROWERS SAID --
PRODUCE SAID ORGANIC PRODUCE.
AND AND SO THE PRICE
DIFFERENTIAL FOR ORGANIC PRODUCE
HAS AS SHRUNK OVER THE YEARS AND
ISN'T QUITE WHAT IT ONCE WAS.
BUT IT WHERE IT DOES COST MORE
IT'S OFTEN BECAUSE THE COST OF
PRODUCTION OR HIGHER FOR
INSTANCE YOU CAN'T.
SPRAY HERBICIDES ON WEEDS -- IN
ORGANIC PRODUCTION.
HALF OF OUR ORGANIZATION WE
OPERATE A PROGRAM TO ASSIST
SCHOOLS WITH BIDS FROM
DISTRIBUTORS -- TO ALLOW THE
SCHOOLS TO ACCESS LOCAL ORGANIC
PRODUCE.
MOST OF THE STUDENTS IN THESE
DISTRICTS RECEIVE FREE OR
REDUCED PRICE MEALS.
THERE'S A LOT OF ENTHUSIASM FROM
THE DISTRICTS WHAT THEY LACK IS --
FUNDING.
SO THIS PRIDE PROGRAM WILL HELP
US UNDERSTAND HOW ADDITIONAL
FUNDING CAN INCREASE THE USE OF
LOCAL ORGANIC PRODUCE.
IN MEALS SERVED TO THESE POOR
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
MARKETS -- FOR CALIFORNIA
FARMERS SO -- WE ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ALISON
JOHNSON SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THEM NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL THE OTHER CO SPONSOR OF
IT.
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING MORE GOOD
FOOD TO SCHOOLS AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE ORGANIC
TO SCHOOL PILOT PROGRAM. ONE
CORD DOMED THE DIRECTOR OF CHILD
NUTRITION AT VACAVILLE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WANTED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK BUT
UNFORTUNATELY HAD A CONFLICT
ARISE SO I'M GOING TO PASS ON A
FEW COMMENTS FROM HIM.
FIRST IN HIS YEARS IN SCHOOL
NUTRITION ONE HAS WITNESSED A
TANGIBLE INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR
HEALTHY FOOD.
PARENTS AND STUDENTS ARE REALLY
CONNECTING THE DOTS THEY KNOW
THAT THE FOOD STUDENTS PUT INTO
THEIR BODIES IMPACTS HOW THEY
FEEL.
HOW THEY FOCUS AND LEARN AND
THEIR LONG TERM HEALTH?
SECOND SCHOOL FOOD PROGRAMS ONLY
THRIVE IF THEY SERVE FOOD THAT
STUDENTS ACTUALLY WANT TO EAT
THAT TASTES GOOD.
VACAVILLE SERVES FRESH LOCAL AND
ORGANICPRODUCE WHENEVER THEY
CAN.
AND THEN ONCE EXPERIENCE THE
STUDENTS REALLY TASTE THE
DIFFERENCE HE'S CURRENTLY
SERVING ABOUT 40% OF THE
DISTRICT'S.
STUDENTS BUT HE'S CONSTANTLY
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO ATTRACT MORE
STUDENTS TO THE SCHOOL MEAL
PROGRAM HE THINKS THAT OFFERING
ORGANIC ITEMS CAN HELP DO THAT.
THE FINAL POINT ON AND MAYBE THE
MOST SURPRISING HAS TO DO WITH
THEFOOD THAT VENDORS OFFER TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. ONE HAS FOUND
THAT VENDORS OFTEN ASSUME THAT
SCHOOLS AREN'T LOOKING FOR AGAIN
IT FOOD SO THEY DON'T EVEN OFFER
IT.
BUT IN REALITY NUTRITION
DIRECTORS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
SEEKING OUT ORGANIC OPTIONS
WHENEVER THEY CAN.
AND FREQUENTLY FINDING THAT
SEASONAL ORGANIC PRODUCE IS NOT
THAT MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE.
OUR HOPE IS THAT THIS PROGRAM
WILL BEGIN TO ADDRESS ALL OF
ONCE POINTS WILL BRING ORGANIC
FOOD TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
LEARNING ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN FOOD AND HEALTH.
IT WILL SHOW ON STUDENTS THE
HEALTHY FOOD CAN ALSO BE TASTY
AND THAT SOME OF THE BEST WITH
THE WORLD GROWS RIGHT IN THEIR
BACKYARD.
AND WILL OFFER SCHOOLS EATEN
OPPORTUNITIES TALK WITH OUR
VENDORS ABOUT WHAT'S REALLY
POSSIBLE IN SCHOOL MEALS EVEN ON
A SMALL BUDGET.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE SPELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CAN AFTERNOON MISTER SHARON
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY AND
THE FRIENDS OF THE EARTH THANK
YOU.
TURN NUMBERS NIKITA CRIED WITH
AN RTC BUT REGISTERING SUPPORT
FOR SPUR AND THE CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED ORGANIC FARMERS THANK
YOU.
MICHAEL GREEN WAS CDS CONSULTING
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE GRANGE WERE VERY MUCH IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
RON RAPPER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD OFTEN JUST MILAN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION
EDIBLE SCHOOLYARDS AND CONSCIOUS
KITCHEN.
MICHAEL DIMMICK FROM RICH OF
CHANGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY -- ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
A SCENE OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE BEEN MOVED
AND SECOND I WAS RECORDING YEAH
IT'S GREAT.
YEAH JUST A A QUESTION FOR YOU
WELL FIRST OF ALL I I SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT YOU HAVE OUR OUR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT AMONG MANY
WHO ARE WHO ARE.
ALREADY IN SUPPORT AND I'M SURE
MY KIDS WOULD CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT GET A BETTER
FOOD AND ORGANIC FOOD AT THE
DISTRICT.
SO AS FAR AS THE THE BUDGET
ISSUE.
HOW MUCH MONEY IS THIS THE RIGHT
THERE ON THE REQUEST? TWO
MILLION DOLLARS MILLION DOLLARS.
AND I'M SOMEWHAT CONFUSED ON ON
WHERE WOULD COME FROM I KNOW
THIS CAME FROM.
ISN'T AG COMMITTEE SO IS DOUBLE
REFERS IS THE POLICY COMMITTEE
HERE TODAY NOT THE BUDGET ISSUE
BUT MONTH FAMILIAR WITH THE THE
BUDGET REQUEST SORRY ARE YOU
ASKING FOR I KNOW IT'S NOT
NINETY EIGHT BUT YOU'RE ASKING --
FOR GENERAL FUND FROM A CERTAIN
AT A NON EDUCATION ENTITY WITH
THE MONEY OR WHERE ARE YOU
WORKING TO GET THE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS.
GENERAL FUND I WASN'T PAYING
ATTENTION TO IT YEAH OKAY.
IS AREYOU TRYING TO GET IT WHO
WOULD IT WOULD IT THE MINISTER
WHERE THE MONEY GO THROUGH IT'S
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NAG.
NAG GOTCHA.
NOT MY LASER QUESTIONS YES.
THAT'S A COOPER YEAH.
AREA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER COMMENT --
WE DID HAVE A TO MOVED AND
SECONDED.
OKAY -- THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE -- I JUST WANT TO SAY
I'VE SEEN THIS PROGRAM WORK OUR
LOCAL FARMERS HAVE BEEN DONATING
ORGANIC FOOD TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND TO SEE THE KIDS THRIVE AND
KNOW WHAT ACTUALLY AHEAD OF
BROCCOLI LOOKS LIKE AND SIT
THERE I WANT TO TAKE PICTURES
WHAT TAKING EATING FRESH FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES ARE RIGHT OUT
THERE BACK THE BACKYARD.
IN THE REALLY SUPPORTS OUR
ORGANIC FARMERS WHO IT TIME
STRUGGLE BECAUSE THEY DON'T OWN
AS MUCH PROPERTY AND THEY NEED A
PLACE -- TO SELL THEIR WARES SO
I THINK THIS IS A FABULOUS JOB
IT'S A GOOD BILL FOR OUR SCHOOL
CHILDREN IT'S A GOOD BILL.
FOR THE HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN
IS A GOOD BILL FOR A FARMER SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I'VE
VOEPEL WEBER.
BILLS OUT HAS FOUR VOTES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE TO MISS RUBIO.
MISS RUBIO HAS -- AB ONE SIX
SEVEN FIVE A MEMBER.
FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT --
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY SEVEN AN
ACT WHICH WOULD INCREASE ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY CHILD CARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS CO CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND IS A
FORMER CLASSROOM TEACHER
EDUCATION HAS BEEN A LIFELONG
PASSION OF MINE.
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY ONLY 9% OF
LOW INCOME INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
AGES THERE ARE TWO THREE ARE
ENROLLED IN SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE.
EVEN IF YOU'RE FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS THAT HAVE THE
GREATEST POSITIVE IMPACT ON LOW
INCOME BABIES.
IN MY DISTRICT 93% OF INFANTS
AND TODDLERS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR SUBSIDIZED CHAIR CHILD CARE
ARE ON UNSERVED 93%.
OUR EDUCATION IS THE BEST TOOL
THAT WE HAVE TO FIGHT LONG TERM
CYCLES OF POVERTY AND TO UP LIVE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR GREAT
STATE.
THIS IS WHY I HAVE INTRODUCED
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY SEVEN
LEGISLATION WILL.
THE LEGISLATION WHICH WILL HELP
CLOSE THE EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY GAP FACING OUR
YOUNGEST CHILDREN BY
STRENGTHENING AND EXPANDING
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS.
AS WE EXPAND OUR INVESTMENT IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WE
SHOULD ENSURE THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS
TO TRULY HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO SUPPORT
THEIR BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
SOCIAL SKILLS AND KINDERGARTEN
READING THIS.
REACH RESEARCH SHOWS THAT HIGH
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS
THAT START EARLIER IN A CHILDS
LIFE MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
AS THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION'S
REPORT HIGHLIGHTED WE NEED EASY
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
WE CAN BUILD ON PROVEN.
UNPROVEN TO GENERATIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT INCLUDE FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT HELP
FAMILIES WITH THE RESOURCES AND
PARENTING SKILLS THEY NEED TO
HELP THEIR CHILDREN SUCCEED.
AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO EGGS
EXISTING CHILD CARE CENTERS AND
FAMILY -- CHILD CARE HOMES TO
RETIRE STANDARDS BASED ON PROVEN
EARLY CHILD HER START MODEL.
FUNDING WOULD SUPPORT FAMILIES
SUPPORT WORKERS TO HELP PARENTS
HEALTH AND OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS BETTER TRAIN TEACHERS
AND CONNECTIONS TO WELL CHILD
HELLO HEALTH AND DENTAL CARE.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THIS KIND OF
COMPREHENSIVE POOR CHILD THE
WHOLE FAMILY APPROACH TO CHILD
DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPMENT HAS THE
BIGGEST IMPACT ON CHILD.
CHILDREN IN POVERTY.
MY BILL ALSO PROPOSES EXPANDING
QUALITY FAMILY CENTERED CHILD
CARE TO TWENTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL INFANTS AND TODDLERS
LIVING IN HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY AND
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE SPONSORS
FROM CONDUCTED ANGLE AND THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MICHELLE STILL A PREVENT
SKI FROM CONTANGO PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AB.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN A KIDDING I WAS
AN EARLY LEARNING NONPROFIT IN
THE LARGEST CHILD CARE PROVIDER
IN THE BAY AREA.
THE REASON GETTING DOWN TO FAX
REPORT CONCLUDED THAT EXPANDING
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY EARLY
EDUCATION IS KEY TO CLOSING
CALIFORNIA'S ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
FOR LOW INCOME.
CHILDREN AND CHILDRENOF COLOR
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT CHILDREN ARE
BEHIND EVEN BEFORE THEY ENTER
THEY ENTER PRESCHOOL -- BY AGE
THREE CHILDREN WITH COLLEGE
EDUCATED PARENTS HAVE A
CALCULATOR IS THAT ARE THREE
TIMES LARGER THAN CHILDREN WHO
HAVE PARENTS WHO DIDN'T COMPLETE
HIGH SCHOOL.
FROM BIRTH TO AGE THREE A
CHILD'S BRAIN DEVELOPS MORE
RAPIDLY THAN DURING ANY OTHER
TIME IN LIFE.
WHICH MEANS THAT WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE THE TRAJECTORY FOR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN.
RIGAS RIGOROUS RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT HIGH QUALITY FAMILY
CENTERED CHILD CARE MAKES A
DIFFERENCE FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS.
PROGRAMS THAT ARE HIGH QUALITY
AND BEGIN IT BIRTH IMPROVE
LANGUAGE AND SOCIAL SKILLS
SCHOOL READINESS AND IN THE LONG
TERM IMPROVE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION AND ADULT EARNINGS.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA'S
ALLOWING TOO MANY LOW INCOME
BABIES TO FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS WITHOUT ACCESS TO THESE
HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS.
AS MENTIONED JUST 9% OF
CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOME INFANTS
AND TODDLERS ARE YOU SAID ARE
ENROLLED IN SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
AND EVEN FEWER ARE IN VERY HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAMS.
AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN WILL HELP
CLOSE THAT REALLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY GAP LIFE EXPANDING
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY FAMILY
CENTERED PROGRAMS THAT INCLUDE
COMPREHENSIVE FAMILY SUPPORTS
FOR DISADVANTAGED INFANTS AND
TODDLERS.
BASED ON THE PROVEN TO
GENERATION EARLY HEAD START
MODEL.
THAT INCLUDES WELL TRAIN
TEACHERS HEALTH AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND HOME VISITS.
THE BILL WOULD SUPPORT EXISTING
A GENERAL CHILD CARE AND FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOMES IN NETWORKS THAT
ARE SERVING INFANTS AND TODDLERS
TO MEET HIGHER QUALITY STANDARDS.
PROVIDERS WOULD GET FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO REACH AND SUSTAIN
THOSE HIGHER LEVELS OF QUALITY.
AND THAT ARE PROVEN TO IMPROVE
CHILDREN'S DEVELOPMENT -- AB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN ALSO SEEKS TO EXPAND
HIGH QUALITY FAMILY CENTERED
CHILD CARE TO TWENTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL CHILDREN.
I REGION I VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS ON
JANICE GALLON I'M A CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA.
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA'S PROUD TO SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY CHILD CARE FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
CDF BELIEVES THAT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THE WHOLE CHILD AND
THEIR FAMILY AND COMMUNITY TO
ENSURE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
FOR ALL CHILDREN ESPECIALLY POOR
CHILDREN AND CHILDREN OF COLOR.
HIGH QUALITY CHILDCARE WITH
COMPREHENSIVE FAMILY AND HEALTH
SUPPORTS -- CRITICAL PREVENTIVE
INVESTMENT TO GIVE CHILDREN A
HEALTHY AND BRIGHT START.
I'D LIKE TO READ A SHORT
STATEMENT FROM A PARENT WHO HOPE
TO BE HERE IN PERSON BUT NEEDED
TO TAKE HER SON TO A MEDICAL
APPOINTMENT.
HELLO MY NAME IS LIZ SAID FROST --
I HAVE TWO CHILDREN WHO ARE
ATTENDING COULD TANGOS CASTLE
MONTH CHILD CARE CENTER IN
OAKLAND.
MY DAUGHTER NATALIA IS FOUR
YEARS OLD AND MY SON ONE CARLOS
IS TWO YEARS OLD.
I WANT MORE FAMILIES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO GREAT CHILD CARE LIKE
WE HAVE.
MY TWO CHILDREN HAVE BENEFITTED
IMMENSELY FROM OF THE EARLY HEAD
START PROGRAM.
I ENROLLED Và THÅU YOU'RE
RIGHT AWAY WHEN THE CENTER
OPENED TWO YEARS AGO.
BUT IT DIDN'T SERVE INFANTS SO I
FOUND A HOME BASED DAYCARE FOR
ONE CARLOS.
HOWEVER THERE WAS AN INCIDENT.
AT THE DAY CARE THAT RESULTED IN
A HOSPITAL VISITS.
IT SHOOK MY CONFIDENCE AND I
DIDN'T FEEL LIKE I COULD TRUST
ANYONE ELSE WITH MY SON.
SO I QUIT MY JOB TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF HIM MYSELF.
THE TIDE WAS FLOURISHING ACCOUNT
SOMEONE AND MAKE AND MAKING BIG
STRIDES IN HER DEVELOPMENT.
I ALSO DEVELOPED WONDERFUL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE TEACHERS
AND SAW FIRST HAND THE SUPPORT
AND CARE THAT THEY PROVIDED
EVERY CHILD.
IT WAS THIS THE GAVE ME THE
CARE OF ONE CARLOS.
AND ROLLED HIM WHEN HE WAS
SEVENTEEN MONTHS OLD AND I WAS
ABLE TO GO BACK TO WORK.
THE SUPPORT OFFERED BY TEACHERS
AND FAMILY ADVOCATES HAS BEEN
AMAZING BOTH IN TERMS OF HELPING
MY CHILDREN DEVELOP.
AND IN PROVIDING ME WITH THE
SKILLS AND RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
MY KIDS INCLUDING HELP WITH
PLACES TO LIVE.
BOTH OF MY KIDS HAVE HAD HELP
WITH SPEECH DELAYS.
THE TEACHERS ALSO HELP ME WITH
TIPS.
SO I CAN NEAR THE THINGS THEY
LEARN AT SCHOOL AT HOME.
ON BEHALF OF LESTAT AND THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PRESENTING EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
YOUR MILEAGE GILMAN CALIFORNIA
CHILD CARE COORDINATORS
ASSOCIATION.
IN THE SAN MATTEO COUNTY
CHILDCARE PARTNERSHIP COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
BETTER MORETERM BEHALF OF
MISSION READINESS READY NATION
AND FIGHT CRIME INVEST IN KIDS
IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL GARCIA LOCAL TRUCKER
PLAN COUNCIL ST CLAIR COUNTY
SUPPORT.
SECOND DAHLE SOME BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
INJURE MUSE FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS A
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THIRTY ONE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TO GIVE ITS CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SAYING NO OPPOSITION WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY SECONDS
IT ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OTHERS MAY
COMMENT I KNOW WE HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS BILL THIS
MORNING.
I THINK THERE'S SOME CHALLENGES
WITH THIS BILL THAT I WISH TO A
WORKED OUT PREVIOUSLY BUT WE
DIDN'T SO WE'LL GET THERE AND NO
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK WITH MISTER
KERR MCCARTY AS WELL SO I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT.
MISS MCCARTY ONE TO MAKE A A
COMMA.
YEAH I I DIDN'T HEAR FROM THE
HEAD START ASSOCIATION THAT THEY
STILL OPPOSED TO THE BILL I KNOW
THIS MIDDLE LETTER [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO I THINK THAT WE NEED TO WORK
WITH THEM ON THE THOSE BRANDING
ISSUES I THINK THERE'S I I
UNDERSTAND WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH BUT THE BIG PICTURE
IS WE HAVE A NEED.
FOR YOU SEE IN CALIFORNIA FROM
BIRTH THROUGH.
FIVE TO MAKE OUR PROGRAMS MORE
BASS AND SERVE MORE FAMILIES
MORE ROBUST AND SERVE MORE
FAMILIES -- WE DID INCREASE THAT
THE RATE THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
IN THE BUDGET TO MAKE IT MORE
VIABLE.
AND IT IT CERTAINLY -- COULD
IMPROVE AS WELL THE COMPANION
BILL THAT WE HAVE ONE CONSENT
TODAY IS GOING TO HELP THAT.
THERE'S AND THIS WOULD WOULD
WOULD GO UP EVEN HIGHER.
THERE ARE SOME BUDGET ISSUES WE
NEED TO SORT OUT AS WELL SOME
SOME SOME POLICY ISSUES SO I
UNDERSTAND -- WHERE WE'RE HEADED
WITH THIS AND -- SUPPORTED AS
MISSED AS CHAIR SAID BUT ONE OF
MAKE SURE THAT WE SORT OUT SOME
OF THESE ISSUES GOING
[inaudible]
FOR THE DRIVER [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RATHER THAN
ME GOING ALL OVER THERE -- I I
ALSO.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL
IN BRINGING FORWARD AND I HAVE
HEARD FROM -- NEIGHBORHOOD
HEALTH I'M NOT AT THE HEAD START
PROGRAM THEY HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION AND USING
THE HEAD START STANDARD WITHOUT
ALL THE PIECES THAT GO TO HEAD
START AND SO FORTH AND SO ON SO.
I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S A NEED.
FOR ADDITIONAL CARE CHILD CARE --
AND SUPPORT FOR INFANTS TO
TODDLERS -- I LIKES SO MANY
OTHERS WOULD REALLY WOULD LOVE
TO US TO HAVE A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM RATHER
THAN A LOT OF PIECES COMING IN
AT ONCE BECAUSE SOMETIMES WHEN
WE DO THE PIECES.
SOMETHING FALLS THROUGH THE
CRACKS AND SO I'M MORE AND AND
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT AT THIS
POINT I WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
HOWEVER THAT ALL OF THOSE
VARIOUS BILLS THAT EXIST FOR
PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE INFANT
CARE IN THE GOVERNOR'S PIECE OF
THE PEACE THEY WANT IN THE
BUDGET AND ALL THESE THINGS.
I THINK CONTINUE TO FRUSTRATE ME
PERSONALLY BECAUSE WE KNOW WE
HAVE IT WE KNOW WE WANT TO DO IT
BUT WE DON'T SEEM TO TAKE THE
TIME. TO HAVE THIS CORD MADE A
CONVERSATION WE GET A LOT OF
DIFFERENT BILLS COMING IN AND
THIS IS A MAJOR PIECE THAT
AFFECTS AN AWFUL LOT OF KIDS AND
SO I WOULD.
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER BOTH OF
YOU ARE DOING -- THE THE EARLY
CARE AND THE INFANT AND TODDLER
PROGRAMS TO BASICALLY FASHION A
CALIFORNIA STATE PROGRAM THAT
HAS MULTIPLE PARTS TO IT BUT HAS
SOME COHESIVENESS TO IT.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I
WANTED TO SEE WITH THAT I THINK
WE ALL SUPPORT IT.
BUT HAVE WE SPENT THE TIME ALL
OF US IN TERMS OF WORK PUTTING
IT TOGETHER SO THAT WE HAVE A
REALLY GOOD.
PROGRAM THAT WE COULD PUT FOR
THE DEALS WITH INFANT TO OR
INFANT CARE ALL THE WAY UP
THROUGH K. TWELVE WEEKS TALK
ABOUT BUT SURELY.
INFANT CARE UP UNTIL THE
ENTRANCE INTO KINDERGARTEN SELF
I I I WAS SUPPORTED TODAY BUT
I'M HOPING I KNOW WHEN I GET
HOME I HITS OUR FOLKS WILL BE
KNOCKING ON MY DOOR AS WELL AS
OTHERS BECAUSE THEY SENT LETTERS --
CONCERNING THIS THIS PROPOSAL
AND ITS ROLE AND THEIR ROLE IN
IT AND THE USE OF THEIR
STANDARDS AND SO FORTH AND SO ON
WITHOUT WHAT THEY SEE IS
OVERSIGHT OR ACCOUNTABILITY OR
SOME KIND OF A THE KIND OF
ACTIVITIES THAT HAPPENS ALL
SUPPORT FOR NOW BUT I HOPE.
YOU SPEND THE TIME BETWEEN
BEFORE IT GETS THE FOR REALLY
WORKING WITH ALL THE PIECES THAT
I SEE COMING FORWARD IN IN
CHILDCARE AND AND PRESCHOOL SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREATER THANK YOU DOCTOR OF AND
I THINK I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT WE
NEED TO START THE MACRO THEN GO
TO THE MICRO.
I THINK THE CLOSEST THING WE
HAVE TO DOING THAT RIGHT NOW IS
A MISTER MCCARTY BILL -- ONE
TWENTY FIVE CERTAINLY NEED EVEN
EXPAND UPON THAT -- BUT THAT'S
KIND OF WHY I THINK WE'RE HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION RIGHT NOW WE
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER -- BECAUSE
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT DOING
THIS IN PIECES I GET CONFUSED I
WHAT PROGRAMS OVER HERE WHAT
PROGRAMS OVER THERE WHAT AGE
BRUSH OVER TRYING TO REACH OF
THIS PROGRAM.
AND WHERE'S THE MONEY COMING
FROM.
NINETY EIGHT NINE NINETY EIGHT
YOU KNOW HEAD START ALL THAT
KIND OF STUFF SO I AGREE WE NEED
A MAP.
AND AND WE NEED TO FIGURE THIS
OUT TOGETHER SO THANK YOU I WITH
THAT -- THE MOTION IS -- YEAH --
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE.
AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
INDICATED -- TO TO YOU EARLIER
TODAY THAT MY COMMITMENT IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO WORK
TOGETHER THAT IS THE FRUSTRATION
OF MINE AS WELL IS THAT WE PIECE
MAIL EVERYTHING AND SOLD MY
COMMITMENT TO YOU IS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT I WORK WITH --
MISTER MCCARTY AND COME UP WITH
A COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE SO THAT
WE CAN PUT FORWARD AT THE END OF
THE DAY THIS IS NOT ABOUT ANY
PARTICULAR BALLOTS ABOUT THE
CHILDREN THAT WE SERVE AND MY
COMMITMENT IS -- TO SERVE THOSE
CHILDREN SO THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER AYE.
THE BUS FIVE VOTES IT IS OUT.
THANK YOU
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY GAP WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM.
THE MISSION OF THE CENTERS TO
ELIMINATE ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS BETWEEN SUBGROUPS OF
STUDENTS AND NEW KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE BY. ONE
PROVIDING PRE SERVICE
PREPARATION OF EDUCATORS IN THE
CSU SYSTEM.
ON EFFECTIVE INSTRUCTIONAL AND
SCHOOL LEADERSHIP PRACTICES IN
THE USE OF DATA. TO SERVING AS A
RESOURCE FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES.
ON ON STRATEGIES FOR CLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS INCLUDING
SERVING AS A CLEARING HOUSE FOR
EVIDENCE BASED STRATEGIES AND
PROMISING PRACTICES FOR CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
ALSO IT -- IF THE CHIPPING GAP
IS A IS A SIGNIFICANT AND
PERSISTENT DISPARITY IN STUDENT
PERFORMANCE AND EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT BETWEEN STUDENT
GROUPS WE KNOW THIS THIS IS
CALIFORNIA'S.
BIGGEST CHALLENGE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
THE GAP BETWEEN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL FOR BOTH BLACK. FOR FOR
BOTH BLACK AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
LATINO STUDENTS AS WOLF IS FOR
STUDENTS WITH A DISABILITY AND
FOSTER YOUTH BY FOURTH GRADE.
WHITE AND ASIAN STUDENTS
CALIFORNIA.
A SCORE ABOVE STATE AVERAGE IS
FOR MATH WELL BLACK AND LATINO
STUDENTS FALL BELOW THOSE
AVERAGES WE KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW THE DATA YOU SEE IT YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON OUR STATE.
CURRENT LAW HAS ESTABLISHED A
SYSTEM OF POLICY MAKING DATA
COLLECTION TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IN PRACTICE.
WITH THERE'S NO ENTITY TASKED
WITH SUPPORTING UNDERGRADUATE.
AND PRE SERVICE PREPARATION OF
EDUCATION.
OF EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND
ALTHOUGH THE AT THE CHEAPER GAP
AS WIDELY STUDIED NATIONALLY AND
STATE WIDE.
IN FACT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE UC
STUDYING IT AND I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT RESEARCH ALWAYS GOES
THE FACT IS WE NEED A ONE STOP
SHOP IN THE STATE WHERE WE CAN
HOUSES INFORMATION.
THE BEST PRACTICES ASSOCIATED
WITH CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
AND WE CAN PUSH THAT INFORMATION
OUT TO RATHER UNIVERSITIES SO
WHY THE CSU.
IT THIS ISSUE BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY IT PRODUCES.
THE MOST TEACHING CREDENTIALS IN
FACT REALLY TO THE C. ISSUES
PRODUCED MOST OF THE TEACHING
CREDENTIALS SO THAT'S A NATURAL
PLACE FOR FOR CENTER SUCH AS
THIS.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A GOOD THING --
AND AGAIN I I THINK IT'S IT'S
THAT ONE STOP SHOP THAT WE NEED
AYE HERE I'LL GET UCLA COME AND
LOOK WHAT WE DID.
AND WHAT I WANT TO NOTE FROM A
VERY YOU SEE WHEN THEY COME IN
AS WELL I WANNA SEE WHAT DID YOU
DO WITH THE INFORMATION WE WERE
THEY ABLE TO USE IT IN A
CLASSROOM.
DID THEY TEACH IT IN A PRE
SERVICE PROGRAM AND I DON'T HEAR
THAT IT'S REALLY HAPPENING SO
AGAIN WE NEED TO FIGURE THIS OUT
AT THAT LEVEL CREATE SUCH AS
CENTER AND MOVE CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN.
FOR OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN ASSOCIATION FOR COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS COUNSELING IN SUPPORT.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
RUNNING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER -- AS YOU POINTED
THEIR WHOLE BUNCH OF SENATE
FLOAT AROUND HERE -- HAVE YOU
MAY CONTACT WITH THAT ONE IN
BERKELEY THAT THE FOSTER CENTER.
I HAVE NOT OKAY BECAUSE THAT'S
FOCUSED ON CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND THEY ARE.
I JUST MET WITH THE DEAN THE
OTHER DAY AND SO THEY HAVE SOME
REALLY -- THEY'VE GOT A PC
PROGRAMS ONE SOME RESEARCH GOING
AND THEY POSTED THE FOSTER
INSTITUTE WORKS WITH THE SCHOOLS
IT WAS NAMED AFTER THE
SUPERINTENDENT WHO WAS KILLED BY
THE SYMBIONESE LIBERATION ARMY
FOLKS SO -- WE JUST MET WITH HIM
THE OTHER DAY AND THEY'RE AND
THEY'RE DOING SOME OF THIS WORK
SO I THINK IT WOULD BE GOOD.
TOO AS A PART OF WHAT YOU'RE
DOING AND I GUESS YOU'RE GIVING
IT TO THE THE CHANCE TO SEE
ISSUE PERSON -- TO ALSO LOOK
INTO IT BUT I THINK THE UC
CAMPUS HAVE SOME OUR PROBLEM --
AS ALWAYS IS THE DISTANCE
BETWEEN THE UNIVERSITY AND THE
COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF WHETHER
NOT WHAT THEY DO ACTUALLY SHARE
IT WITH THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WOULD TAKE IT.
SO I I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA I
THINK THERE'S SOME THAT ARE
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE THIS
DOESN'T PARALLEL WITH I DON'T
KNOW WHAT WE DID WITH THE L. CFF
WE STARTED UP.
A PERSON WHO'S SUPPOSED TO BE IN
CHARGE OF WAS CONE AT ONE POINT
IS THAT STILL IN EXISTENCE.
THAT'S THAT'S GOOD STAFF RIGHT
THERE I GOT.
DOES IT ALL THE TIME OKAY I
MIGHT BE ABLE TO THIS ONE OF MY
OWN THOUGH YEAH. ONE OF HER
BETTER MOMENTS RIGHT THERE --
BUT I YES THAT IS IN EXISTENCE
AND I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THAT
ENTITY IS DOING YES.
I REALLY DO -- BECAUSE OF WHAT
I'VE I THINK WHAT I'M REALLY
GETTING AT IS WERE OPERATING IN
SILOS.
IN MANY PLACES EVEN THIS
BERKELEY THIS IS A THAT'S THE
BERKELEY THE SAME HAND AGAIN I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
RIGHT SO -- BUT I DO KNOW THE
LIKE THE UC'S ARE DOING A LOT OF
RESEARCH FOR THE ARE PRODUCING A
LOT OF TEACHER CREDENTIAL
CANDIDATES RIGHT THAT'S REALLY
DONE AT THE CSU LEVEL BY MARCH.
AND THAT'S WHAT I MEAN I I I
WANT TO TAKE THAT RESEARCH I
WANNA USE THAT RESEARCH I WANT
TO USE THE KNOWLEDGE OF ALL AND
HE'S AND PUT IT ONE PLACE SO
IT'S HOUSE.
AND WE CAN IDENTIFY THE BEST
PRACTICES CERTAINLY INFUSE IT IN
OUR TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS BUT ALSO GET IT INTO
OUR SCHOOLS AS WELL AND I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE DO
THIS BECAUSE I I GET A LOT OF
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR TO
LOOK AT WE'RE DOING WHAT.
WE'RE DOING WITH.
I I CAN'T BE THE THE GUY THAT
HOUSES THIS WE NEED A PLACE IN
THIS STATE WORDS HOUSE AND WE
CAN FIGURE OUT SOME PROTOCOLS TO
PUSH IT OUT.
AND I THINK WE HAVE A CAUGHT
HAVE OUGHT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE C. C. E.
OR WHATEVER WE CALL IT --
BECAUSE THEY NOW MOVED --
WRITING THIS AND ALMOST STATE.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW THE TEACHER
CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES THEY'RE
PRODUCING THERE BUT QUITE
FRANKLY.
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP BY LARGE NOT
ALWAYS IS ASSOCIATED WITH WITH
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND AND CERTAINLY SOME
OTHER FACTORS.
IN A NEEDS TO BE IN THOSE AREAS.
WHERE THERE ISN'T URBAN SCHOOL
TRANSFORMATION CENTER AT SAN
DIEGO STATE WITH DR JILL JOHNSON --
AND IT IS OF OF RESEARCH
INSTITUTE AS WELL AS THE FACULTY
DEVELOPMENT IS TEACHER TRAINING
PROGRAM -- SO THEIR THEIR NUMBER
OF THEM OUT THERE I I'M NOT SURE
WHETHER -- DOING ANOTHER ONE IS
IS ANY WE CAN TRY IT AND SEE
OVER THE IF YOU GIVE THIS TO THE
CHANCELLOR THEY WILL LOOK TO SEE
WHAT'S IN THEIR SYSTEM AND TRY
TO COORDINATE THAT BETTER.
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE OF AND
THE SOME OF THE GREAT WORK AND
SOME OF THEM DO A LOT OF
RESEARCH WORK WOULD NEVER RELATE
TO CAMPUSES OUR SCHOOLS.
URBAN SCHOOL TRANSFORMATION
RELATES TO SCHOOLS AND THEY WORK
WITH SEVERAL SCHOOLS ACTUALLY
AND HAVE BASICALLY DEMONSTRATE
THOSE SCHOOLS CAN IMPROVE IN SAN
DIEGO SO IT'S SO THEIR NUMBER
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THOUGH THAT THAT WHATEVER
THEY'RE DOING IS IS PUT TO A
HIGHER LEVEL SO THAT WE CAN.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT AND UTILIZE
IT AS WELL AS OTHER FOLKS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE AND MAYBE IT'S
ISSUE FUNDING OR WHATEVER MAY BE
BUT I THINK.
BREAKING IT TO THE TO THE C.
ISSUE WHAT WOULD THIS DOES MOST
OF THE THE CREDENTIALING OF THE
STATE OF WOULD BE GOOD SO I I
SUPPORT THIS I JUST HOPE THAT WE
PAY ATTENTION TO SOME OF THE
ONES THAT ARE OUT THERE IN THIS
AND THE CHANCELLOR SHOULD.
KNOW THEM I MEAN THEY YOU I
ASSUME THEY SHOULD KNOW WHO'S ON
THEIR CAMPUSES TO WHICH THESE
MAJOR RESEARCH INSTITUTES YEAH.
ADDED BY I GUESS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE -- AGAIN I'M INTO
THE ONE STOP SHOP RIGHT -- AND
THAT DOES MEAN FOR RESEARCH THAT
JUST MEANS HOUSING IT AND THE
BEST PRACTICES ASSOCIATED WITH A
VARIETY OF THINGS GOING ON IN
THE CLASSROOM.
AND AND AND I EVEN MY OWN ROLE
HERE SOMETIMES I I STRUGGLE WITH
THIS PLACE OVER HERE THIS PLACE
OVER HERE AND THEY'RE ALL DOING.
PROBABLY GREAT STUFF BUT I DON'T
THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT WHAT
EACH OTHER'S DOING SOME SEEKING
SOME COMMUNICATION YEAH WELL I
THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT THE LC
AFFECTING WAS GOING TO DO BUT AT
I HAVEN'T SEEN LET ME ANYBODY
SHOW UP FOR THAT.
YEAH I I I I I A DINNER WILL BE
BLUNT WITH YOU WITH THE CENTER
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT I
CAN TELL YOU THE FULL NAME OF I
CAN'T EVEN.
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION EASY
SOMETHING -- I THINK THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS A REAL PROBLEM.
THE FACT THAT WERE FUNDING THEM
AND DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS A REAL PROBLEM.
AND I THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM
THAT WE NEED TO FIX AND SO I
THINK WE'LL DO THAT TOGETHER
OKAY SOUNDS GOOD.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE.
WAS A BLUNT ENOUGH MISTER CHAIR --
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISTRAL DONNA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AS FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY I'D KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
I WEBER.
EVER I AM.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IN IS
OUT.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM IS CARILLO.
GIVE ME ONE MOMENT WHAT WE GOT
HERE [inaudible]
AB. SEVEN TWENTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE THING ON OKAY.
VERY PROUD TO BE PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN TWENTY
FIVE A BILL THAT PROVIDES URGENT
AND ONGOING PROTECTION. TO OUR
CRITICAL AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION SAFETY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS ASUS.
PROGRAMS ARE CORNERSTONES FOR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IN THESE
PROGRAMS IMPROVE SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE GRADUATION RATES AND
CONNECTION WITHIN THE WITHIN
STUDENT PEERS.
IN CALIFORNIA THIS PROGRAM SERVE
MORE THAN. FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS AT FOUR THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED SCHOOLS EVERY DAY.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE OFTEN
ESSENTIAL FOR WORKING PARENTS
WHO WORK TIRELESSLY TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN BUT OFTEN
CANNOT AFFORD AFTER SCHOOL CHILD
CARE.
HOWEVER OVER TIME COST TO
OPERATE THESE PROGRAMS HAS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY.
SINCE ACES WAS IMPLEMENTED THE
CALIFORNIA MAN MINIMUM WAGE HAS
INCREASED BY 50%.
AND THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX HAS
INCREASED BY 30% WHILE THE DAILY
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR ASUS HAS
ONLY INCREASED BY 9% AS A RESULT
THESE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE
FREQUENTLY STRUGGLE TO STAY OPEN.
ACCORDING TO THE SURVEY
REPRESENTING MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITHOUT A FUNDING
REQUEST ONE IN FOUR PROGRAMS.
EXPECT TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS TO
ABOUT NINETY WANTS TO NINETY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FIVE PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND TWELVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION AND
CONTINUOUS FUNDING.
OUT TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION FOR THESE CRITICAL
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AS
BRINGING THE FUNDING FORMULA
FROM EIGHT DOLLARS AND NINETEEN
CENTS TO NINE DOLLARS AND
SEVENTY FIVE CENTS.
PER STUDENT EVERY DAY WHICH TO
BE QUITE HONEST IT'S NOT EVEN
QUITE ENOUGH.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE WILL
ALLOW ASUS.
FUNDING TO GROW WITH FUTURE
MINIMUM WAGE AND COST OF LIVING
INCREASES TO CONTINUE SERVING
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND I WILL
ALLOW MY WITNESSES TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES THANK YOU.
GET AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WENDY
AGREES AND I'M PROUD TO BE HERE
TODAY AS A PRODUCT OF AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
I GREW UP IN THE MOST DANGEROUS
ONE MILE RADIUS IN LOS ANGELES
IN THE NINETIES.
WITH MY MOTHER HAVING PASSED AND
MY FATHER BEING AT WORK MY
SIBLINGS AND I WERE LEFT ALONE.
WALKING TO SCHOOL OR WALKING
HOME MEANT TAKING MY LIFE IN MY
HANDS.
AT THE TIME LITTLE HANDS AT THE
MERCY OF RANGING GANG VIOLENCE.
DURING MY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AGE
FUNERALS WERE REGULAR FUNCTION.
THROUGH ALLEYS BEST AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM I LEARNED REAL REAL
WORLD SKILLS.
THIS NOT BE TAUGHT ME TO MAKING
COOKING CLASS BECAME THE DINNER
I MADE FOR MY SIBLINGS AT NIGHT.
WHAT KIDS MY AGE WERE LEFT TO
HANG OUT AND BECOME ENTRENCHED
UNLAWFUL ACTIVITY OR BECOME THE
VICTIMS OF IT?
I WAS AT LA'S BEST IN MY AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM.
THIS IS WHY AFTER SCHOOL MEANS
SO MUCH TO ME.
I WAS ENCOURAGED AND I WAS
BELIEVED IN.
THE INTRODUCED ME TO A WORLD I
NEVER KNEW.
MY AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM TAUGHT
ME TO BE RESILIENT AND I AM
FOREVER GRATEFUL FOR THE QUALITY
OF THE LIFE I LIVE BECAUSE OF
THIS.
I AM NOW PARENTS.
AND I DEPEND ON MY AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM FOR MY DAUGHTER'S.
MY HUSBAND AND I BOTH NEED TO
WORK FULL TIME TO MAKE A LIVING.
AND TO PROVIDE FOR THEM.
WE DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY OF
PICKING THEM UP RIGHT AFTER
SCHOOL.
WHILE WE WORK.
WE KNOW OUR CHILDREN ARE SAFE
AND THEY'RE LEARNING IN THE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM.
BUT AFTER SCHOOL GOES BEYOND
JUST HEALTHCARE.
MY DAUGHTERS ARE THRIVING.
AS THEY PARTICIPATE IN SCIENCE
CLUB SOFTBALL DANCE DRILL AND SO
MUCH MORE.
THESE ACTIVITIES TEACH THEM
IMPORTANT SKILLS.
BUILD THEIR CONFIDENCE.
AND GIVE THEM ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES THEY OTHERWISE
WOULD NOT HAVE.
AS AN ALUMNI AND AS A PARENT.
I CAN ATTEST TO AFTER SCHOOL IS
NOT SOMETHING EXTRA.
IT IS A FUNDAMENTAL NEEDED ALL
CHILDREN SHOULD HAVE ACCESS.
TO I WOULD NOT BE HERE IF NOT
FROM AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM.
PLEASE FULFILL CALIFORNIA'S
PROMISE TO OUR CHILDREN.
BY MAKING SURE THAT OTHER
CHILDREN HAVE THAT SAME
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU.
CHEN D. CHECK FROM THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL ADVOCACY
ALLIANCE.
REPRESENT IT'S A COLD STATEWIDE
COALITION REPRESENTING THE
INTERESTS OF THE HALF A MILLION
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
SERVED BY A PUBLICLY FUNDED
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY DAY WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
TWELVE TO SAVE THE STATE'S HIGH
QUALITY AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
THESE PROGRAMS.
IMPROVE SCHOOL ATTENDANCE REDUCE
DROPOUT RATES HELP ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS TRANSITION TO
PROFICIENCY BUILD SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL SKILLS.
PROMOTE CAREER EXPLORATION ALL
WHILE THEY'RE ALSO REDUCING
CRIME SERVING NUTRITIOUS MEALS
AND PROVIDING CRITICAL CHILD
CARE FOR CHILDREN.
AS YOUNG AS FIVE YEARS OLD FOR
WORKING PARENTS.
BUT WITHOUT SAID AB.
SEVENTEEN TWELVE I'M SORRY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE
CALIFORNIA'S SYSTEM OF AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS WILL IMMEDIATELY
BEGIN TO COLLAPSE.
EACH TIME THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FROM THE STATE ASUS
PROGRAM SINK DEEPER INTO DEFICIT.
TODAY PROGRAMS ARE STRETCHED TO
THE BREAKING POINT AND ARE
BRACING FOR ANOTHER MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE IN JANUARY.
AS AN EXAMPLE LA'S BEST AFTER
SCHOOL ENRICHMENT PROGRAM THE
PROGRAM THAT SUPPORTED MISS
REESE.
WHEN SHE WAS GROWING UP AND NOW
SUPPORTS OUR CHILDREN WELL
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING
THEY SHEER LA'S BEST PLANS TO
CUT OUR PROGRAMS FOR SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS?
AND SPORTS PROGRAMS FOR TWELVE
THOUSAND THEY WILL ALSO HAVE TO
REDUCE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR NEW STAFF.
GOING FROM THIRTY HOURS TO TEN
HOURS WHICH IS VITAL TO STUDENT
SUCCESS AND WELL BEING.
THESE KINDS OF CUTS ARE
HAPPENING ALREADY.
AND BE A NEXT YEAR PROGRAMS ARE
AT RISK OF SHUTTING DOWN ACROSS
THE STATE AT URBAN AND RURAL
SCHOOLS A LIGHT.
AND THE IMPACT OF THESE CUTS AN
IMPENDING CLOSURES FALL ON OUR
STUDENTS MOST OF WHOM QUALIFY
FOR FREE AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS
AND AT MISS RUIZ'S PROGRAM
NEARLY 90% UALIFY.
CHILDREN NEED AND DESERVE THE
EXPERIENCES AND SUPPORT
ESSENTIAL FOR THEIR FUTURE
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE OR
THEIR FAMILY'S INCOME.
AND UNLESS THE STATE TAKES
ACTION THESE STUDENTS WILL LOSE
THEIR HUNDREDS OF ADDITIONAL
LEARNING HOURS THAT HELP CLOSE
THE ACHIEVEMENT AN OPPORTUNITY.
GAP THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TWO CABBAGE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
KEVIN TURN AROUND HALF THE
COUNTY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FLEXIBLE EDUCATORS
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ALREADY BE ON BEHALF OF LA'S
BEST AFTER SCHOOL ENRICHMENT
PROGRAM IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OLDER SHAILA WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT.
CAME IN TO MEET YOU AT TECHNION
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
DEBORAH BROWN WITH CHILDREN NOW
IN SUPPORT.
KILLING JOURNAL BE A FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ALLIANCE OF
YMCAS IN SUPPORT.
HEATHER WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
AFTER SCHOOL NETWORK STRONG
SUPPORT.
BETTER MORE TERRIBLE HAVE
MISSION READINESS AND FIGHT
CRIME INVEST IN KIDS AND WE ARE
AN EXTREMELY STRONG SUPPORT.
STREAMING.
NICK WRONGLY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LINES OF BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUBS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
GREAT DAY AT BRINGING IT BACK
ANY COMMENTS READY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
BEEN MOVED.
I WILL SECOND IT -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALSO I'M SORRY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE STAFF AND
I WANT TO THANK OUR WITNESS WHO
CAME DOWN FROM LOS ANGELES MISS
REESE WHO IS AN ALUMNI OF
VALLEY'S BEST HAS CHILDREN
ANALYZE BEST.
AND IT'S A TESTAMENT OF HOW
THESE PROGRAMS WORK ACROSS OUR
STATE AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST YOU
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I'VE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I THE BILL.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR NOW GOING TO MOVE YOU WERE
GONNA TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR NOW MISTER CALLERS HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
IT REMOVED AND OF THE SECOND I
MISTER KALRA.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM TO AB ONE TWENTY FOUR
DO PASSED YOU APPROPRIATIONS
FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE TWENTY
FIVE TO PASS YOUR PREPARATIONS
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B..
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN TO PASS
YOUR PREPARATIONS FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AB FIFTEEN OH EIGHT TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL I'VE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
SMITH.
SMITH I AM VOEPEL.
WELL I WEBER.
WEBER I SIX THERE ARE SIX VOTES
SO WITH THE CONSENT COLOR SIX
VOTE SO IT IS OUT.
NOW WE HAVE BILLS ON CALL.
ARE YOU GOING TO LIVE THE CALLS
INDIVIDUALLY -- SO THE SECRETARY
WILL -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON EACH MEASUREMENT CALL BRIDGE
MEASURE UNCLE.
FILE ITEM ONE AB ONE TWENTY
THREE THE CHAIR VOTING I AM
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA I'D VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING WEBER
[inaudible]
UBER I BY THE THE BILL HAS VIA
VOTED IS OUT.
FILE ITEM FIVE AB FOR FIFTY TO
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I SEVEN THE BILL HAS SEVEN
VOTES A BEFORE HAVE YOU TWO IS
OUT.
FILE ITEM SEVEN A. B. SEVEN
ELEVEN THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING WEBER.
WEBER I FOR VOTE THE BILL HAS --
AB SEVEN ELEVEN WHO HAS FOUR
VOTED HIS HOUSE.
FILE ITEM NINE AB [inaudible]
EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL I'LL KILEY.
KILEY I'VE KALRA [inaudible]
I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
SEVEN THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
AB -- EIGHT SEVEN FIVE IS OUT.
FILE ITEM TEN A. B..
NINE OH EIGHT WE NEED A MOTION
ON EIGHTY NINE AWAY.
MOVED AND SECONDED.
HELLO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL.
FILE ITEM TEN A. B..
NINE OH EIGHT VOEPEL AYE WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I AB NINE AWAY AS SOME
VOTED IS OUT.
FILE ITEM TWELVE A. B.. ONE ZERO
ZERO ONE O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL AYE KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA I HELLO.
HELL I'D WEBER.
WEBER AYE. SEVEN AB ONE ZERO
ZERO ONE AS A SEVEN NOTES IT IS
OUT.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TEN NINETY
EIGHT THE CHAIR VOTING AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA EYES VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE WEBER.
WEBER I'D.
SEVEN THOSE SEVEN VOTED IS OUT
AB.
TEN NINETY FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
AB [inaudible]
ELEVEN NINETY SIX REMOVED.
WE HAVE SECOND SECOND AYE MR
MCCARTY.
THE MOTION IS THE PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH HI
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTED
IS OUT.
FILE ADD ONE TWENTY THREE A. B.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FOR THE CHAIR
VOTING HI KALRA.
KALRA I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTED
IS OUT.
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL AYE MOTION.
AND YES WE DID.
CONFIDENCE IS.
KALRA.
KALRA NOT VOTING MCCARTY --
MCCARTY NOT VOTING WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL IS FIVE AUTISM.
FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE THE CHAIR
VOTING HI KALRA.
KALRA EYES MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I BY THE WELL AS FIVE
VOTED AS A THE THAT THAT.
AND THEN WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OF FOR MEMBERS NOT PRESENT
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WAIT.
I GET THE WRONG MORE THAN
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I AM
.
LIKE I SAID AS A G. FIGURE THIS
OUT.
HEARING IS ADJOURNED DISAGREE
YOU REMAIN SEATED SO WE CAN DO
THE ADD ONS
--
CERVANTES FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY CONSENT
CALENDAR.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I'VE.
AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN THE CHAIR
VOTING I KALRA.
KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
NUMBER [inaudible]
FOUR FIVE VOEPEL I THERE IS AN
LIKE PLAYING BINGO.
FILE ITEM SIX AB FIVE SEVENTY
EIGHT KALRA.
KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
WELL I AND WEBER [inaudible]
UBER I'VE.
FILE ITEM SEVEN A. B. SEVEN
ELEVEN MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I FILE ITEM ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT KALRA.
KALRA I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO KALRA.
ALL RIGHT I'LL VOEPEL.
WILL TELL AYE AND WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I'VE.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN A. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I'VE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY A. B. FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT KALRA.
A MAJOR KALRA FIVE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I AND WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I'VE.
AND I THINK THAT'S IT
[inaudible]
RIGHT
OKAY
.
I BELIEVE THERE IS ANY.
I REMEMBER ONCE [inaudible]
CHELSEA.
PLANS IS LONG
[inaudible]
YEAH
THESE.
MY ANSWER ON